Listen to me.
Dirty fucks cause among going to say this,
once the end of the world show,
there's 68 fucking tickets left there,
probably all spread out.
You're probably not going to
get to sit with your buddies,
but you got to have to deal with
that shit. Okay? That's how,
that's how the world works.
If you don't get your shit
together early and get the tickets,
you're going to have to live in
the fucking boonies for the show.
You're going to have to just go out there,
get your freak on,
sit with some other people. They will
probably be wearing desk squad tee shirts.
You'll be fine. Honey, honey band,
Joey motherfucking Diaz,
Doug,
Stan hope and Wa 1221 2012 will
it really be the end of the world?
The fuck knows. No one's ever predicted
anything, right? Ever. Do you know that?
Do you know that? Okay, and
if the Mayans were so clever,
where the fuck are they
now? Exactly. I don't know.
This podcast is brought to
you by [inaudible] dot com
if you go to o n n I t.com
and get yourself some Alpha brain or
some shroom tech or some upgraded coffee.
We just started selling Dave Asprey's
bulletproof coffee. Did you know that?
A lot of coffee when you buy it,
this is really kind of crazy,
but a lot of coffee when you're buying
it, it has a fungus on it, so it's,
it's not healthy for you.
I did not know that until we went to j.
We have the Dave Asprey podcasts
and he explained it to us. Uh, his,
his coffee does not have any of those
issues is he believes that that's the one
of the reasons why coffee
has gotten a bad rap, um,
from people as far as health test,
he feels like more tests
need to be done because the,
the negative health repercussions,
he believes a lot of them stem from
toxic mold. It's on your coffee.
It's crazy shit.
If you go to bulletproof exec.com,
he'll explain everything far better than
me because he's actually smart and not
just repeating shit that smart people
have already figured out like me. Um,
also at Onnit we sell kettle bells and
battle ropes and basically all shit
manly.
Okay.
If you look at and get your fucking your
life together and live at your optimum
best,
we sell all sorts of supplements for that
and we got a lot of crazy shit coming
down the pipe. We have a lot
of new stuff, uh, at on it.
We're constantly trying to hone your pill
ad you were working on a testosterone
booster.
There's apparently a bunch of different
natural herbs like I'm tongue got Ali
and a bunch of different ones that
have actually been shown to have a real
effect on, uh, on the, uh, your, your
body's production of testosterone.
It's fascinating standing instant boner
pills that I don't need this. You need,
well, you need that stuff that you were
taking, which was basically a, some of a,
a Viagara. They kind of like
fudge it according to a Aubrey.
Aubrey explained to us how these
a boner pills work when you buy,
like those are the supermarket
or drugstore or whatever.
Those actually do work.
And one of the reasons why they work is
because a lot of these companies they
take and they buy,
uh,
I forget the exact chemical name
for Viagara but whatever it is,
they buy that stuff in bulk and then they
throw it in their supplements. So yeah,
you take it,
you get a boner cause it's Fiat agree.
Fuck.
Cause I guess there's like this loophole
where the FCC or not the FCC with the
FD. Yeah. And WIA and
Drug Administration. Yeah.
They give you like a warning if they catch
you and so like a little fine and you
know,
and then
if you get, if you get busted again like
the third time, apparently it's big one.
It'll just change the cause.
That's what the boner pills are.
We don't have anything fake.
Okay. Everything we're selling,
especially with regards to supplements,
it's very important.
Brian and I sort of agreed this when
we first started taking on sponsors,
we didn't want to take on anybody shady.
We've passed on people we've
had some offers for, you know,
would have paid us
money that we were like,
I don't think we shouldn't
be involved with that.
We only want to be involved with
people that are doing legit,
honorable things.
And one of the coolest things
about [inaudible] is the
supplements are very good
that the highest quality available,
but if you don't like,
if you order 30 pills of Alpha brain,
you try it and say,
this doesn't do anything for me. You
get, you can get 100% of your money back.
You don't have to return the product.
Do you say the shit sucks? That's how,
first of all, how confident we
are that we'll we're selling.
You actually works if you're a mass
and your health is not in order.
You got a neat deal with that first
before you think about any of the facts of
supplements,
especially something subtle and a,
although effective like nootropics. You
got to get your body together. Okay,
do you eat healthy?
Drink a fuck load of water.
If you're taking opiates, stop.
If you're smoking cigarettes,
please try to stop. Drink a fuck load
of water. Take yourself was that,
don't take the powder. If you don't,
you ever find this boner pill at that?
Don't take it. It's not good. No,
because I thought it was good
cause the guy said was awesome.
But look at the bottom right.
It says one capsule for three days.
I had a boner for three days,
so don't do that.
Oh well you know what that means
apparently, but the way it works is
there's Viagra but then there's
Cialis and Cialis, Cialis.
I almost will last like a couple of days.
So that's probably what they put in now.
All right, well that's
not a good idea. Yeah,
they're selling you,
they're selling you some fucking
drugs and they're sneaking them in.
Well that's the thing about
supplements. It's like, it's really,
it's a funky thing because the government,
although obviously they don't do the
best job of regulating the dangerous
chemicals and, and, and um,
actual pharmaceutical drugs because
there's a lot of them that wind up being
like really dangerous.
A lot of them that they pass at p people
wind up dying from getting strokes.
And I mean,
we've all heard those late night lawsuits
where someone who was on x drug for,
you know,
during the period of this year,
in that year when it's snuck through
and something was really bad for you.
But the supplement industry is
not really regulated at all.
It's really kind of a wild west situation.
That's why it's really difficult when
it comes to something like a nootropic.
It's like this is this really work cause
this real there on on a.com if you go
there, this is a science page
that explains all of the, the,
the clinical studies that have been done
in the various ingredients and what's
good about them and what's been shown,
how they've been shown to improve
people's scores. Uh, anecdotal evidence,
I'm a huge fan of it.
I'm a poker players.
A lot of poker players love Alpha brain.
It's just another thing that you should
be doing to keep your body functioning
at an optimal level. It's not
the one thing that's going
to fix you, but it is a,
another thing that will help you.
It is all the various
nutrients that support the the
brain's production of human
neurotransmitters. And even Dennis
Mckenna was impressed by our ingredients,
which was very exciting. Use Account
Code, name, Rogan and save yourself. Um,
10% off any and all supplements.
All right. Your Fox.
We have too many pot.
We have too many sponsors
live anymore. Yeah, we have a
fucking shitload. We've done.
You want to say something?
Yeah, I just got my ting. Fun.
Yes. Sponsor. How crazy. Huh?
I said that's our next sponsor
because they finally get,
gave me one of these
Samsung Galaxy s three,
which had been playing around like
crazy with and it's great man.
And that fucking big scream
really is a big difference.
Game Changer when you go online. Yeah.
It's a game changer. Apple, you fucked up.
You should've just admitted
that you fucked up and went,
went with the bigger screen. Yeah.
Who's working over the apple now?
Steve jobs probably would have
went with a bigger screen. And you,
it feels great about it because I,
I'm going to be using it as my,
my second phone is that you,
if you don't want to like pay for
it, you could just lower your, your,
your minutes down to almost nothing
per month. I think that the lowest,
it was like six bucks a month for
having like just nothing like, you know,
so how many minutes is it?
Uh,
I think you pay per minute when you're
down at six bucks a month. Oh Wow.
So it's like when you're
in a foreign country,
so like you could just pretty much like
Jeff fall off the face of the planet
with that phone.
If you want to know.
I know a lot of people have down
to like no phone calls right there.
They're like, oh, you texted me if
you called them up, they don't answer.
And it's just say, don't leave
me a message. Leave me a tax.
I don't listen to my voicemails.
I know like 10 people that,
that rocket like that.
What Tang is a what Brian's talking about.
Unfortunately honey, honey, it's
just sitting here staring at nothing.
Just nothing here,
but then they have bad ass phones and
they're pretty much unlocked on tings
network. So you could pretty
much just get sweet phone.
You don't have to have in any contract.
You go there. And I think if you put in,
what does it, ting slash Joe Rogan. It's
broken.ting.com if you go to Rogan dot.
Yeah,
ting.com you first of all, you save
50 bucks off of uh, any of these.
A really sweet android phones.
They have the uh, the note as well,
which is that Samsung fucking
giant tablet phone most.
It's so ridiculous. It's so
awesome though. I that Ma, I
must possess it. It's like,
can I have to add in your pocket?
When I look at it,
I get envy because people at shows that
come and they take pictures with me
after the shows and they all, so many of
them have that note in that always go,
Ooh, I wish I had your phone,
your phone. I've got phone envy.
The galaxy s three is the phone MV.
I'm fine with that. That one's fine.
It doesn't really need to be any bigger,
but the iPhone, it leaves me lacking.
I'm sad.
Dad,
do you remember we've had phone in envy
for so long mean you like you would have
like the, the east seven 15 we're like,
oh my God, they just the e eight 15
like the Motorola flip phone,
stupid phones.
But I took a great fucking picture with
that phone when the greatest pictures
that ever took him by the hooker, the
hooker when we're working in downtown La.
And uh, it was not the downtown
La of today, which is a,
what's that word?
What's that word when they move into
a neighborhood gentrify black cloud,
black cloud or wipe out.
This woman was walking by and she was
heating a meatball sub and she had a wig
on and she was an overweight
African-american Hooker.
And I looked at her and, and she goes,
how you doing? I go, what's up baby?
And she pulls a tid out as I'm taking
a picture of her with a meatball sub in
one hand and a tit and the other.
And it's perfectly framed.
Like if I was a conspiracy theorist,
I would say, well, this was fake.
This is obviously Photoshop.
This never really took place.
Do you think it's perfectly frank? I think
it's online, right? You find it, pull it,
pull it up. Oh, it's a woman's breast.
It's not even pornographic,
disturbing looking like it.
You can see a male's breasts.
Why can't you see a woman's breasts?
You know what's fascinating?
You can see Chazz Palminteri is brass.
Did you know that? Yes. Not
Chazz. Palminteri Chaz Bono.
I get them confused.
The Bronxdale.
I bet you could find it. I bet you
could see his as well. He's married.
No disrespect to Mr Palminteri.
It was a slip and met Chaz Bono who used
to be used to be chastity Bono and then
it's a famous daughter of share and got
a sex change while there was like these
photos of her walking down the beach
topless because now she's a man.
Now she's got like a beard,
so she's allowed to walk topless.
So she's taking advantage of that
and she's walking topless and she's,
that's her. That's her. That's the girl.
That's the lady that is a real picture.
Pull that shit up all the way
Ustream was with us. Don't worry.
Brattle will be fine with it. Dot.
Don't do it, Brian. I'll do that.
Just show them. Show them the meatball
sub. Just the meatball sub in a hand.
Come on photos. Perfectly framed. Listen,
do you can you can Photoshop one,
make a copy of that.
Make a copy of that and just put
a little blurry on the nipple
that only take you a second ago.
Can you do that Brian?
The folks that are listening to this
are not getting the full experience,
but you could find,
what is the v how'd you,
if you just type a black hooker
Rogan, there you go. That's my girl.
Greatest picture I ever took and I took
it. One of those stupid flip phones.
So the phones at tin has are a farce
period there. They're the best,
the best android phones
that you could buy.
Imagine the aerial is on those phones.
They must be crazy.
It'd be so crystal clear. Then people
would really say that. I faked it. Um, it,
it's an awesome company.
They don't have contracts.
They have really reasonable
rates. And if, uh,
if you don't use all the minutes in your
plan, they refund you the money on your,
the next bill. That's tit. They knock
your next bill down. It's like, it's
like the best company. It's like
they're ethical. They're not evil.
It's possible to run a
business and not be evil.
It's possible to provide
an excellent service,
which by the way is off the sprint
backbone there on the sprint backbone.
So you're getting sprint coverage.
You're getting, it's not like, you know,
fucking Fred cell phone service.
It's like legit.
It's a huge nationwide network that's
really excellent. And it's CDMA,
which I prefer to GSM. GSMS
at T. And. T. I have both,
but I'm a t and t works better overseas.
Most people accepted overseas,
but CDMA,
I find like Verizon and sprint,
I find that it's just seems to be a better
coverage. That's just where we live.
rogan.ting.com go there.
Save yourself 50 bucks.
You dirty fucks.
You got that video game.
It's pretty bad ass that I've
been playing. Yes. Kerosene games.
This is our last sponsor. Um, blade
slinger is this game that kerosene games.
Uh, we, you know, we want to
make sure, again as we said,
that anything we get involved
with is something that, you know,
we would actually use something that we
would actually enjoy and something that
is coming from, you know,
a really a good place.
There's a lot of video games that
they make for the iPad that really,
they're not really iPad games.
They're like PC games that they it
over to it and they kind of suck.
A lot of them suck the way that uh,
this this company, kerosene games,
it makes plates slingers done it.
They've made this game from the
ground up for IPAD and iPhone.
So it's very intuitive
touch controls and with the,
the ability that they have these
processors for these iPads now and,
and phones,
it's like that was always like an issue
with computer games back in the day was
like, could your video
card handle it? You know,
like really like stunning graphics.
You remember like playing quake and
those games when video cards were first
coming out and people would have like
dual sli where they would have to video
cards just to,
just to power the graphics.
Well these fucking iPads
are so powerful now.
I mean you could see really
amazing graphics on an IFAD.
It's, it's really nuts.
We live in strange times. You just
say it. [inaudible] I didn't say that.
I just repeated you iPad
goddammit. Slip of the tongue. Uh,
the game is called blade slimmer.
This is their first game.
It will be out for the android operating
system in January or February and it
will probably only work on like
the more advanced android phones.
Like the newer cause android, you
know, they have like ice cream,
what does an ice cream Sundae or something
like that have a bunch of like weird
names and their operating systems,
they constantly,
so as long as you have like the,
the latest shit it'll probably work for,
it's a good one. Uh, but again,
the game is blade slinger.
It's a fucking bad ass game. It's only
$2 and 99 cents, which I, you know,
I think it's on Sarah, right?
Oh, that's right. That's right.
It's on sale for 99 cents.
I think the end of the year you should
totally buy it. Now it's nine, 9 cents.
What the fuck is, you know, if you
can't, if you can get a homeless person,
a dollar,
you can buy
game, uh, that, that will,
yeah, that's ridiculous.
That's amazing. I didn't know that. Yeah,
I didn't even think about it that way.
You know,
like a homeless guy on a
dollar. Yeah. Like this is
something that you will enjoy.
That homeless guys is going to
be like woo. Dolor yes, exactly.
And this guy, um, this game, uh,
what the fuck are you talking about?
If you go to, if you go to kerosene
games.com, forward slash blade slinger,
right. There's a, a really a, a
cool a preview. You could actually,
we could actually show it here and it'll
look good as opposed to at my stupid
studio, which has shit Internet
bandwidth, have a new studio,
but the Internet sucks a fat one. So we're
here. That's what we're here. Oh dear.
A points unknown.
You can't tell the people on the
Internet where the fuck your studio is.
Is the phone number, man. I just
want to call and talk to you anyway.
Go there. Go check it out. Go Fuck
Yourself. Okay honey, honey is here.
Goddammit. Video that blade. Sing.
Sure. Put it on. Oh wait, nevermind.
There's an advertisement, an
advertisement first. Come on. Period.
Second advertisement or whoever,
or kerosene games. Listen to me.
Take that fucking ad.
You're selling of video game and you're
going to have an ad, the front of it.
They're fucking you man. All right, so the
ruin and your click through rates. Okay.
All right. This doesn't
have one. Here we go. Okay,
so this is uh,
the game graphics actually,
which looks like to me almost
like an x box and a ps three
is a deserted. He sends his days of war.
May Not, that's not the real narrator.
The narrator,
this is a four year old kid.
One of the things we want
to call attention to here
and integrate. So there's,
this is,
this is just like a,
a like one of those where
it's a preview of the game,
but it's a trailer
or anything. Yeah, it's a,
but it's cool. You use your,
your iPad to like swipe and you know,
do certain signs when you're,
you're attacking and stuff like that.
But uh, the graphics are amazing.
It's a fun game. And uh, I think they're
going to be adding onto it cause it's, it,
you know,
it's a,
it's a game that I see has like a good
future where they can just add new maps
and stuff like that cause they already
have the, uh, the groundwork down.
So yeah.
Powerful Blade Center. Yeah, go
check it out. Like I said, it's a,
it's a dollar now that's a,
that's the latest. So, uh,
they're very happy with it.
It's for until December 29th or so,
and then returned return to
its normal price. So, uh,
right now get it for a buck.
You are not paying attention.
We're selling people selling souls,
souls, $1 some seriously high
technology. Honey, honey,
is he Brian? Cue The music.
Let's get the party started.
That was probably a long
ass series of brochures.
The Joe Rogan experience,
Joe Rogan podcast,
my night,
our commercials on long, they're
wordy, but we get them out of the way
and then once they're done,
they're done but shorter than Thomson.
Her and Christina has it.
[inaudible] podcasts.
They have long commercials
than us. Yeah. Every time I,
I count to where they actually start
the show, it's like 26 minutes in.
They do at the same style where they
just start talking and then they sort of
fuck around and go off on tangents and
they go back to tour dates and stuff. No.
Well, it's weird. That's how we started
it. Yeah. It's a good way to do it though,
I think.
You know,
they keep trying to pressure me to put
commercials inside of podcasts and I keep
telling him to go fuck themselves and
casually. No, they bring it up, you know,
they say we would like you to
start introducing commercials
in the middle of the
podcast and they can be prerecorded
and we'll stick them in afterwards.
But that seems,
that seems sleazy.
That seems like it interrupts the
flow of the conversation, right? Yeah.
You guys hammered yet? I feel warmth
and I feel warm and toasty. Yeah,
we're drinking maker's mark.
Shout outs. Shout out to my boy.
Justin loves this shit. Hey
Justin, my friend Justin,
we were telling him to go out yard.
Yarders a shit. Bikers. Magrigen coke.
Why put the coconut though?
Why don't I just go right with the maker?
Because he's seven feet tall. He does
whatever the fuck he wants to trust me.
Justin wants to put coke in his
makers. You just let him. Wow.
He's a biggest human.
I know.
I like zero slow mover. Uh, well.
I mean you might be able to outrun
them. It might be, but God damn,
when he caught you, you'd be in
fucking lots of trouble. He said,
I have a friend who was a true giant,
really sweetheart of a guy.
This is the dude.
Yeah,
it was a true giant is enormous and
talks like a normal guy. But he's like,
he's just a huge fucking guy,
you know?
That's funny how people are like,
just not created equal. You know,
there's dudes like that. There's a
whole art, our tour manager is six,
seven and he talks about that a lot. He's
like, it's really difficult. You know,
you go to like when we're on tour at
the holiday and he's like in the shower
only comes up to my
chest between my nipples.
He's big and tall, you know what I mean?
Is he can never find pants that fit him.
He liked to, to represent pants.
I was watching TV today, uh,
and there was a fight from 19 or 2009.
This guy semi shelt send me, Shell used
to be the k one Grand Prix champion.
I think he's won at least
three if not four times.
He's six foot 11 six foot 11 300 pounds.
And it's just like good luck
cause go fight that guy.
He's a fucking legit giant.
I mean he really is a giant,
small and mighty though.
Like what about that guy was like,
not once the big guys learn how to fight.
The big guys learn how to fight too.
The idea is that the small man with
skill can overcome the big man who has no
skill. I, I still maintain that most
most of the time. That's accurate,
but a big man was skill is a fucking
pain in the ass like this stupid ones.
You would like to think that everybody
would like to think the good looking guy.
Good looking women.
A lot
of people would like to
think they're stupid.
Nobody wants to think there's a girl who
is way harder than you and also a way
smarter than you. That's
too, that's depressing. Yeah.
It's suppressing his fuck.
That bitch just got all aces. You know?
She was born with a bunch of aces. Boobs.
Yeah. It's not fair. It's
not. It's totally not fair,
but that's life and they have to deal
with everybody trying to drag them down.
I'm must. Yeah, I would guess,
I would guess it would be really hard
to be a hot check to deal with a lot of
country women.
I've seen women get country
with pretty girls for no reason.
Like someone will come up and like ask
for directions or something like that.
I've seen like Condi women
just immediately going,
do you know where you're going?
Like where I, you know, how,
how much do you know this area? You
know, like immediately like dismissive.
Yeah. I like that girl stealing
something from her by existing,
but being in front of her, she's
not a sister. She's not a, you know,
a fellow human to be,
that's like someone who's taking away
from your value by their very existence.
You know?
I knew a girl who got furious at a guy
because he brought a really hot girl to
her wedding and everybody was paying
attention to the girl. What? So yeah,
she literally said, you know,
she was like yelling at him.
Why the fuck did you bring
that bitch to my wedding?
And me and the girl was like a sweetheart.
She's very nice girl.
Didn't do anything to anybody,
but just because she was there,
she dressed nice and she was apparently,
she was very beautiful
and the bride was furious.
Like it took away from her big day and
she kept saying that that fucking bitch,
she took away from my big
day and then amazing God,
the whole wedding thing
fucking freaks me out.
That's that pressure of it needing
to be this huge monumental thing.
She's a crazy bitch. Like I,
she got a divorce immediately
in me. I do not pass go.
I don't have no idea.
He told me the whole story,
but my buddy told me the whole story.
I was not there,
but it was a fascinating story. It's like
animals. You know, I was talking about,
uh, I've had females, female dogs,
female dogs do not like other female dogs.
They just don't like each other.
A dog world is fascinating. They will
fight if death, if we were able to,
um, communicate with each other like dogs
where we would just be peeing on each
other all day, Huh? Yeah.
And humping in public on the
regular figure out who the Alpha is.
He gets to breathe.
It's amazing.
Ben, Ben's Dog van has a dog
named Larry Bird. Oh, that's
awesome. That Larry Brits.
I got pictures. He's great. He's fucking
awesome. Awesome. Very. You know he,
he's really, he's really
Zinn. The dog is. He is, yeah.
He doesn't really bark at all.
He just like,
he wants to be scratched on
the head are very good friends.
A friend of a friend found him on the
freeway in Nashville and we moved to town.
Ben's been saying he wanted a dog and a,
my buddy posted an ad on Facebook
and said, hey, we have this dog.
We're looking for a good home.
And he's got very long legs
and kind of an awkward face.
So the name Larry Byrd came to mind,
kind of Darcy is, he's an Australian
shepherd. It looks bit size.
Probably 45 pounds.
Yeah.
But I don't know if he's zen or if he's
just real stressed out all the time.
It's shutting down. Like I can't get very
stressed when Ben leaves. Yeah, I bet.
Well the, you know, it's like all the
sudden he's got something good, you know,
and he's got someone who cares for him
and loves him. I had a female like that.
I had a female than I uh,
adopted and she was eating out
of garbage is when I got her.
She was all covered in mange.
Yeah.
I took her in and start
feeding or taking care of her,
but she would have a massive
anxiety when I would leave.
She would know what to do.
She would freak out because she
didn't think I was coming back.
You know when you,
you know,
you get down to that point like she was
like starving to death and I found her
like literally in downtown La.
She was just eating out of garbage cans,
big dogs. They have access to so much
Joe. It was, things were so happy.
Sometimes you get lucky just
as bummed out too. Well,
it's such humans too. It's like
if you get lucky, you could get,
you could grow up in a really awesome
household where your mom and dad love you
and they want to see you all
the time. And, and you know,
you're growing up with people that have
sort of a sense of perspective and they
can educate you on the ways of the
world and constantly give you love.
Or You could grow up with a crazy
fucking shithead mom and a nutty fucking
violent, abusive drug addict, Dad,
and you're fucked. You just fucked.
You were born into the wrong
spot and he's nothing he did.
And your entire potential
completely changes because of that.
Your entire way of absorbing the world,
of even just dealing with
reality is compromised by
this situation that you were
born into with no, no effort of
your own, no Karma behind it.
No nothing. You just were there unless
you believe in reincarnation, you know,
unless you believe in,
you know,
it wasn't just no fucking
evidence to support any of that.
But the idea that people were responsible,
especially like babies are responsible
for terrible things that happened to them
because of things that they did
in the past life. I'd have to say,
Jesus fucking Christ help counties,
the universe,
will you let a baby slide, you know, no,
punish it from some shit that some
other entity had done in the past life.
It's so ridiculous. It's just, um, it's,
it's super sad aspect of this world.
So your life could be awesome or it could
be shit and it's just depending on who
gives birth to you and where are you are,
you know,
I mean, we're lucky as file. We,
I'm crying lucky as fuck you and I,
all of us here and to live in America
to live in 2012 in America with fucking
medicine and doctors and the
Internet and all this shit.
Well, it's interesting how
the are challenges change
as you're right. Like, yeah.
It's kind of a, it's weird. I was, I,
you know, one of my best friends in Ohio,
uh, he, he got really mad about a cell
phone bill. He found out that since like,
I don't know, 2007 or something,
he paid t-mobile $5,000,
which is I think normal. If you were
to add that up. And he was like,
this is ridiculous. He's, I want
to spend my money on other things.
So he stopped using a cell phone for
three months. He didn't have a cell phone.
He used a land line or would
communicate through email on he,
he was telling me how difficult it was.
But how like incredibly liberating,
you know,
and not that that's a problem.
I'm kind of segwaying into just like
you're talking about how we've evolved and
like technology makes everything so easy.
Everything is like you could,
you could take care of things at your
house right now with your cell phone
because you have robots there. Yeah.
Yeah. But it's so interesting. You know,
I've always been fascinated
with people who could, um,
who were incredibly resourceful
with nature, like boy
scouts and stuff like that.
Yeah. And like how like just to
go home and make a fire right now,
like a little bit of, I, yeah, I sticks
together, whittled myself a coffee table
and I find that to be
incredibly fascinating.
It really actually had some spare time.
Would like to learn a few
tips if anybody has any,
do you want to be like a subsistence?
Well, I want to know how to,
I want to know how to make my own
boat and arrows really. Have you ever
watch any of those shows?
Like a Alaska shows where they like,
these people are like, uh,
homesteaders out there and they,
they gather all their food within
the summer months and then they,
they're fucking freezer dicks off for like
eight months out of the year. Amazing.
Yeah. If you're into that, if you're
like, you're talking about like,
I like people like living off the land
and like trying to survive out there is a
fucking fascinating, crazy. And this
is generations after generations.
These people just live like that.
Yeah.
There's this level of awareness
and oneness with nature
that I think is so cool.
Like when you can, you know something,
you know, you're just like, you're,
you're in the earth and so,
you know,
obviously I don't really have
too much experience with that.
I know I'm really good at fishing. I
like to fish. Good. Really? Yeah. Yeah.
I'm good at it.
I know how to catch them.
You like the shit you're like ready for
like bass pro masters tournaments and
shit.
Not really red pass master.
Do I do
fish that fishermen make a fuck
load of mine. Did you know that?
Like professional fishermen?
Yeah.
You can make a great living if
you're like a famous fishermen. Yeah.
How hilarious is that? This famous
fisherman I think. I think we should try.
You want to try something?
You start entering the tournaments.
I mean you're in Nashville. It's like
some great bass fishing down in that area
to this.
I think the world record from the south.
That's the same thing though.
That whole oneness like that just
becomes part of their, you know,
their receptive faculties is
they know the, the fucking water.
They know about the fish.
Yeah. What's going on?
They know they don't like that kind
of tackle that lore. It doesn't work.
Yeah. It certainly becomes, you know,
you have this connection with this
animal that you're going after trying to
figure out how to keep pulling them out
of their world, but tricking them with,
with fake fish. You know what a for
ruthless fucking game fishing is.
You throw out this impossibly
beautiful wiggling,
sparkly thing that makes a poor fish,
just want to go bite it. And he,
he bites it and it gets literally
pulled out of the dimension.
He exists in another dimension
that he can't survive in.
He can't move,
he can't fly around in it
like you can in the water.
Like all of a sudden he's in air
and like what the fuck is going on?
And if we pulled them right
and if it's deep enough water,
they'll die just from the pressure
just from going through the deep, deep,
deep water to the surface there. Boy,
like they can't even handle it. Like,
what are we doing out here?
We're supposed to be at like 700 feet of
water and just yank those fuckers up to
the surface and they're just
like, ah, you're really,
you're really ruining it for
me now. Sorry, there goes my
fishing boner. No, listen,
fishing is awesome. I love fishing,
but it's gotta be a fucking,
a real freak out for that. Poor
Barracuda, I no bites down on your lure.
And then all of a sudden they're not
the rich or they're like, oh yeah,
they're definitely a top shell fish.
I think they're,
I don't think they're tropical.
That'll be think people eat them
that much to their favorite song.
Yeah. Did you ever, uh, like, did
you like cars when you were a kid?
Like that band heart to sing that song?
Barracuda,
they had a bunch of great songs.
I like heart and yes.
What do you have for me?
Brian redband are fixing shit.
No disrespect to the vag
pills and what have you.
But what happened to the old fashioned
boners? I mean, just good old fashioned.
Well,
SSRI has killed a lot of them.
A lot of people on antidepressants
have a huge problem getting wood. Oh,
I'm normal.
Boners but it's nice to have
like that five hour boner boner
while you're like, all
right, I'll take care of you.
You're just trying to challenge
yourself. Really. Yeah.
I want to see how much bone or I
can have Olympic Boehner style.
That's marathon Boehner sex.
But here's my question. Um,
your, your partner, I mean, I mean,
are they having sex for eight hours
because that sounds kind of painful. Well,
he mostly sleeves.
He mostly slaves,
flux conscious, well played.
That's Brian's thing.
Just gives them Ghp he takes
by Agora called Bro rape. Bro.
You gotta be careful about that.
You can't even use it's real.
Or if you joke about rape,
you support rape. Did you
know that? Stop? Oh, careful.
Careful. No. One of the
things I've been noticed,
I posted this on Twitter
about a lot of lefties.
This is a funny thing lately
where I'm like hardcore lefties,
you know, [inaudible] like to
call themselves progressives.
They will criticize stereotypical
Muslims and television and film.
Like I saw these, uh, these progressive's
that we're criticizing homeland.
Yeah. That all of the Muslim
characters are cartoonish, you know,
and it's like, and it's, I
find it offensive. They were
like finding it offensive,
but it's hilarious that they would never
do that with cartoonish Christians.
Like if there was like a, you know,
a TV show and all the Christians had,
God hates fags posters and we're
walking around that you would never hear
progressive's bitching about
fundamentalist Christians that are
represented in a cartoonish way.
But fundamentalist Muslims, it's like, oh,
we have to be aware and conscious and
we have to be like really sensitive to
like these foreign people in their
ideas like wackadoos that are brown.
Like you have to be like really
kind to them and show them kind of,
but wackadoos that are white and
look too much like your relatives.
Like fuck them. Fuck, fuck
the Christians. Fuck them.
And little let them be as
cartoonish as possible.
But you have to be super sensitive about
the way people who, you know, Islam.
It is,
it's not all terrorists are not Islam
as if one ideology makes any more sense
than another ideology as any of these
fucking goofy calls make any sense,
any of them. But progressive's if they
don't want to criticize Islam lately,
it's like these cartoonish
Muslim characters. Okay.
That's kind of how I feel about culture
isn't that does as much of cold as any
of the other ones being progressive as
called for sure. The, the, the hardcore
lefty stance is a cult. I mean,
there's shit that fits in and it
doesn't fit in. It's like when,
when it comes to gun control and these
horrible fucking mass shootings have been
going on lately,
you know,
everybody's answer is always gun control
from the left and everybody from the
right is they need to arm people to
make sure that this can't happen because
you're not going into an unarmed area.
And that if people had guns of their own,
they would know, you know, they, they
couldn't just do this. I mean, you know,
it's a complex issue,
so it's,
but anyone from the left never
recognizes that. It's always,
it's always gun control. You fucking, and
the right people, are you happy? You know,
we can fucking believe this shit.
Why do you need a gun?
Why do you find a new hobby?
You don't need to hide.
Well, it's really interesting
to discuss this topic, um,
because we just moved to
Nashville and that's a gun town.
There's guns everywhere. And, um, I have
friends that carry concealed weapons. Um,
this,
there's this one girl,
she's super hot chick and she's always
got a little pistol in her purse,
like no big deal. But I think that
something that's, um, you know,
maybe I'll tell you about it at a
later date. Um, I think that, uh,
you know, it's, it's a really interesting
feeling to be in, in a town, in,
in a community with that. And
where I see it is that like, we,
we've heard all these stories, stories of
like, um, don't worry mom, dad, I'm safe.
But, um, you know, like our
friend, like friends of friends
getting shot, um, people,
people being, you know,
shot several links,
all these different stories and you know,
there's a lot of crime everywhere.
But you know, they had, they had this, uh,
turn your gun in day to like try and
reduce the, the firearm pop population.
But like at the end of the day, like
I don't, I'm not pro gun or anti gun,
I don't even know what I am,
but I'm just like,
I was thinking about it and I'm like,
the bad guys aren't going to turn
their guns in. You know, and you know,
it's a noble,
it's a noble cause to try and
alleviate violence of any kind.
But at the same time it's like they're
already there and I just don't see how
they could go away, but I
don't, I'm not making that fuck.
That's like a strong statement and you're
making a logical statement because the
real issue is not whether
or not we change the laws,
it's whether or not people won't break
those laws. And the majority of crimes,
violent crimes with guns,
I believe in this country are
committed with illegal guns.
So it's already this weird situation.
The kid who was,
who was in possession of these guns,
these were his mother's guns. I mean,
you talk about gun control,
he was,
he violated a bunch of different laws
before you ever left the house by just
handling these guns and loading them.
And taking them out of it
and weren't his to fuck with.
So he was violating laws and then the,
then the law.
Then the question is why
do these things even exist?
Why does someone need an assault rifle?
Those are legitimate questions.
Those are questions that we really should
consider. There's no doubt about it,
but the idea that we need to take
all guns away, like it's like,
that doesn't make any sense.
Like if people want it to look,
a Timothy Mcveigh did with a truck
and some fertilizer, people want to,
they can kill people in in a bunch of
different ways with a bunch of different
shit that you can get in his plans
for it on the Internet. It's amazing.
We really stop and think about it.
How many people there are that?
There's 300 million of us at least plus
Mexicans in this country and we only
have this many crazy, people weren't
running around shooting people. It's,
it's really kind of
shocking. It's amazingly good
considering the, the numbers.
It's just when something does happen,
it's so horrible and so heart
wrenching and you, you know it, it,
it fucks with our heads though.
The real statistics though,
if you think about how many people
actually have guns and how many people are
running around shooting people,
it's amazing.
It's amazing how behaved everybody is.
Most part,
if you just look at the actual
numbers of human beings is there's,
this is a crazy time to be alive.
There's 300 million people in this
continent driving around in cars getting
stuck in traffic and the amount of
people that actually shoot people's
relatively small,
but when you compare it to other
countries with stricter gun control laws,
you see those numbers drop.
That's a hard,
but the issue is they've already had that.
They, you know, it's like the, you know,
the, the, the question of
how do you take the guns,
I mean you'd have to go door to door.
You don't have to storm houses. You know,
it's like how would you eradicate
the guns from our neighborhood?
The way they have an England, the
England, they never really habit.
So when you see like low UK gun
violence rates, it's like, yeah,
they never really had the guns. Even the
cops don't have them, you know, those,
they do.
They have them in case of
extreme situations like
American Werewolf in London,
Wolf gets out if that's when they busted,
you can't fuck with a werewolf and
you got a Billy club, silly bitch,
silver bullet. Anyway, there's, I
think there's arguments on both sides.
There's definitely
arguments on both sides.
But you know what the other argument is?
The unsung discussion is what was his
kid on? What was going on with his head?
Was He medicated? Was he on? Who knows
what from the time he was a child?
Do you know how many fucking
kids get put on Ritalin?
Do you have any fucking kids get put on
antidepressants like an un, a young age.
We live in stir range times of just
manipulating with human neuro chemistry.
And especially when you're,
you're mixing things which people do.
And we will take illegal drugs with legal
drugs and it's a psychotic combination,
you know? Uh, the Zoloft
and cocaine. It's like,
it's famous for people going
fucking Berserk on it. Try that.
Just kidding.
It's a, well, it's interesting to know
what was, what was wrong with this kid,
you know, whether he had a mental
illness, whether he was, uh, uh,
whether he was medicated,
what was,
there was obviously something fucking
really wrong with him just to be able to
do that. Just to be able to do
physically what he did and shoot kids.
There's gotta be something right.
Way Wrong.
I was worried,
I was thinking about this the other day
about like all these mass shootings and
all the people responsible for them.
And you know,
I wonder if there were to be an,
I mean,
maybe they're already doing this
and I'm foolish, I don't know.
But if you were to dissect their brains
and literally if there was like some
sort of similar common thread of an
excess of chemical or something or like
Hitler,
what about him finding out the bad,
you know like saying that
there was a human race,
like there's a right way to have a
brain and you know what I mean? Like,
like you have to be blonde, blue eyes,
you know, and anyone else, you know.
So you're saying fine.
Common Trait [inaudible] he's saying and
I was like I can't drop them in the lab
running.
He's really funny.
I common trait of somebody that's fucked
up in their head and put it on my side.
Pro Vigil. So give me
some, what did he die?
You need to get some sense of self,
a good doctor to difficult thing to
talk about because it's, it's horrific.
It's her, right. Cause it's
still everybody's, you know,
it's so painful and I think that the
end of the day there isn't anything that
we're going to find out
or be able to fix it.
Whether it's gun control or
anything other than trying to,
trying to be as a community, more
aware of each other. You know,
we're talking about all these things
about like at your fingertips and like
we're, you know, we've,
we've got cell phones that do
everything for us and nobody,
like, I think people stop paying
attention to things like, just the,
the most rudimentary level of,
of human existence and,
and communication of just like really
seeing someone and being in touch with
them.
And I think some people get isolated
and more and more isolated and,
and I don't, I don't fucking know, you
know, I just, I'll only speak for myself,
you know,
there's a lot of us and the problem is
we can't be looking out for everybody
around us when we're not even in
contact with them. We live in these,
these communities where,
you know, there's people,
there's a guy who lives right down the
street from you is to whore houses down.
He wouldn't be able to pick them out
in a lineup. And then, yeah, that's me.
I don't fucking know all my neighbors.
And you know,
I live in a community of people that
are basically strangers, you know,
and they're strangers to their community.
And that's not how it used to be.
There's something that happened to us
when we invented automobiles and mass
transit.
And the ability to move
along great distances is we
don't live in work clothes.
We,
we,
we don't have the same sort of community
that people did before they had cars.
And that's sort of how human
beings were invented or rather, uh,
how human beings develop. They did, we
developed to grow up in these communities,
tribes where we all stick together. We
all hunted together, we, we farm together,
we gathered again,
we raise each other's children and then
someone figured out cars and it just
stopped.
I just started like,
let's live in the fucking east
side and let's drive up cross town.
I want to live in a suburb. So I'd
love to have a house in the mountains.
And then everybody was able to just
go wherever the fuck they want it to.
And then they would meet for work
or go over each other's houses.
But the sense of community
got further and further apart.
Like I've had this conversations
with some of my friends were like,
why don't we all like live in the
same neighborhood, man? You know,
why don't we do that?
Wouldn't that be awesome if you lived
across the street from me? I can't.
We make that happen.
Like let's like live it fun to play
basketball with you all the time.
But that would be fine.
I'd be,
I mean like wouldn't it be amazing
if you could like literally live in a
community of all of your friends?
I don't know anybody who does that
except like there's these guys, uh,
this mixed martial arts
guys in Sacramento, uh,
Uriah Faber and all of his friends,
they got a situation where they bought
a bunch of houses in the same call,
the sac, I think. And they just all live
next to each other, which is awesome.
That's the way to do it.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think that'd be really cool.
But it's funny to talk about like
tribal existence where we're,
many of us have come from your, I think
we're, we've all come from, you know, the,
the tribal existence was everybody
worked together as you know,
woven into the same cloth and,
but everybody had like a, uh,
a job to do and an end to hold up.
And we're in a society where everyone's
just an individual, you know,
for the most part.
And it's really interesting to think
about if we were going to, you know,
to try to, um, have like a communal
type thing. Again, I don't,
I don't know.
Well, we wouldn't have to, if we lost our
ability to travel distances, that would,
would really fuck a lot of people up
if something happened and society was
thrown into chaos and we lost our ability
to get oil and gas. And that's not,
that's not that far outside the
realm of possibility. You know,
if we look at the face of the earth,
like when scientists start like going
into the past and see some of the
cataclysmic events that have happened,
like, you know, the predate human beings.
There's been some, uh, some
big ones, like a lot of them,
like a whole shit load of them and it's
really possible that one could happen
and if it did happen,
we would lose all electricity essentially
forever for the rest of your life.
It'd be no more electricity because no
one's going to be able to figure out how
to fucking fix it without any real
infrastructure available anymore.
And you'd have a few people that
were by living off the land,
you'd have a few people, I mean
that we could go back to that again,
like that one supervolcano one asteroid,
there was an asteroid that just flew by
and the Chinese got these photographs of
it.
I retweeted it.
Oh it's,
it flies by every four years
and it's over a mile wide.
Some mile wide piece of rock that flies
really close to us every year or every
four years. It's a mile and a half
wide. Sorry, a mile and a half wide.
What the fuck?
What's going to happen is times pick
Friday when the end of the world comes and
we've got some stragglers, which will
clearly be the majority of the well turn.
You know, I feel like this is a
real hotspot for um, you know,
survivors.
That's right.
So we're going to have to come up
with a game plan of um, you know,
I'll bring the canned goods and
make sure the ratio was good though.
I feel like there's going
to be a lot of dudes,
it's going to be a lot of sausage.
Should have bring a lot of booze factory.
How many breathable females.
Yeah, that's the problem.
Some board games we
have to be real careful.
It was to really make sure
we protect our genetics,
their whole fate of the human. Russell.
So now you're talking like Hitler though.
A lot of good points.
This is crazy. If you had like me, look,
if you had some real
engineering of the human race,
you would have to do some culling.
Right? It's like when you,
you have a thorn or a Rose Bush and
you have some fucking wacky branches,
you've got to trim them bitches. We accept
that. We accept that scientifically.
We accept that in the nature world,
the world of animals and plants,
but we don't accept it with people.
We connect emotions to the most horrific
and fucked up amongst us and we don't
even want to kill them. You know?
We don't have one kill bad people.
We don't want to prune them.
We don't want to send them to
the electric chair is barbaric.
You know it's lethal injections.
Horrific. We're no better than them.
What are you doing son? I don't know
why that is. What are you doing playing,
watching cowboy porn?
No,
I was looking for that asteroid and
then an ad came up on this website.
You just tweeted at us about the
last thing you ever want to do.
Expert Lindsey as the brain of the killer.
I don't know.
She talk about this right now.
Yeah, I saw that. That
was a documentary. Yeah.
It was a guy who found out that he passed
all the tests for being a sociopath or
psychopath,
whichever one that is.
I was going to bring this up earlier
too. There's this article, it says,
I am Adam Lanza as mother and it's
about this woman, or excuse me,
this woman is talking about her own son
who has a lot of similarities between
him and the shooter from
this, uh, from Sandy Hook.
And there's all these,
if my phone was kind of freezing here,
but it's talking about their struggles
with him and you know, the, the,
the diagnosis,
they're giving them all the mood altering
drugs and they just don't know how to
handle a kid with this type of brain.
Um,
and that's when it
comes back to,
we've been talking about this a lot,
just like how do you approach
the mental health aspect of this?
And it's such an inexact science. It's
like, how do you treat these kids?
We don't really know what's going on if
the treatment is making them worse or
better. And that's kind of the gray area
that we're stuck in, it seems like. Right?
Yeah.
And we also don't understand
why a person develops that way.
What makes a person a sociopath? What
makes a person a psychopath? Is it,
is it nature? Is it nurture? You know, it,
everyone's different. There's different,
there's a gradient live. Do you mean
there's like a spectrum of different,
there's people that are just
a little crazy. They're okay,
but they're just a little crazy.
And then there's people that literally
don't see reality the way we all agree it
looks right.
There's these people that you see them
sitting on the side of the road and
they're talking to themselves in their
covered in dirt and they haven't washed
in the year and they're not in back and
forth and having conversations like,
okay, what's that guy seeing?
What's going on? I mean,
he's having a fucking full
blown conversation with
people that aren't even there.
What's going on? What's going on
there? And we don't exactly know.
We know how to give them some drugs and
make them not do that. And you know,
we know there's something wrong was
his firing mechanism is fucking noodle.
But we don't exactly know what
that guy seeing. You know,
he could tell us what he'd
be, might be lying, who know?
You might be seeing some shit that he
doesn't even like talk about and see
seeing dragons, you know,
considerable amount of mushrooms.
Then you would know what he was saying.
I doubt it. I say we try it. Well,
I see your point.
Lastly,
you want to do is get locked into a
homeless dudes way of thanking you,
become him. I think I take it back to
imagine people pulling the brains out on,
on LSD. Like that guy from
pink Floyd that they, uh,
they wrote that song shine
on you crazy diamond there.
That's apparently about a dude who
lost his mind on some LSD. You could,
you could fuck up.
You fuck up and go deep.
And Suzanne just got nervous and
reach for the market. Not Nervous.
I'm smart straight.
I'm accessing my pleasure energy.
How does that sound? The booze energy.
That's the pleasure energy. I too love it.
Everything's fine guys. Don't worry.
It's, you know, do you find, um,
there's a lot of resistance to talking
about loving it, that people like, Hey,
actually I found this is
really funny. I, we got to,
well we talk about booze
all the time because I,
I'm, I'm not an alcoholic,
but I love Bourbon. You know,
I don't drink bourbon every day, but um,
you know, I talk about it cause you know,
I'm comfortable that way and we've had
a few emails here and there, um, some,
some dude with like,
I saw you at your show when you were on
tour and you just looked so tired and
look, drugs have torn into people here.
And I was like, let me just go, let me,
let's just go right over this again.
You saw me on tour and I look tired.
That is a shocker
parking lot and I, I, I'm not going to
throw them under the bus, you
know, to be concerned. Right.
But it's, you know, well,
you know,
from his point,
there's a lot of people that think
that the life of a showbiz person,
it's just fucking drugs and barely keeping
it together and stumbling on to stay
the night that,
you know,
dude, I know, I mean at the same
time, I'm fully aware of that side.
Like I, it does exist. It totally,
and you should, you know, I'm sure,
cause it's like when you're on the road
and you're just moving all the time and
you're never in the same place, you're
never in this like you're fucking lonely.
You know, you're, there's
just so much going on,
like drinking, um, you know,
it was a real couple repetition.
Oh yeah. Cause you're going to,
you're in a different club every night,
but there's always,
and everybody wants to party with you.
But at the same time, I really, um,
I don't, I don't like, I like,
I love to drink, but I don't,
I don't like being wasted.
I don't like not being in control
and I don't like losing my voice.
So there's like a balance, you
know, and I'm just, I feel,
I feel really lucky that I have a partner
who's, you know, we, we do this together.
Like if one of us was slipping there,
that would there be a lot to
handle. But we're, we're pretty,
we're going to drag each other.
You're probably slipping down
together. I go slow erosion nicely.
You can count on each other.
I remember one time both keep your shit.
I remember one time when we were really,
when we first started touring together,
Ben got really drunk and I helped,
he had real long hair and
I know this parabolic cute.
Oh that's sweet. I tied it in a
ponytail. So he looked like a,
like a yoga instructor and then like
probably like a few days later I got,
I got a little drunk and I remember like
I passed out with like my boots on and
I remember like,
well I let a whole squad or these guys
from the show and just went to town on
her. Yeah. That's really,
that's really fun.
I think you just contributed to
rape culture. I was going to say,
and I'm going to call you out really Joe.
Really,
it's cool that you guys can
count on each other that you know
that you're both in it to, you know,
to do the right shit, you know,
to get it done that you know,
you're both in it to make great music.
You know,
it's like a lot of bands have an issue.
Like there's like five guys
come on that as the picture
and that you can see it flows
block out the nipple because apparently
it almost sunk CBS when Janet Jackson
whipped one out. Who knows what it
could do to Ustream, but this, uh,
this lady with her, her 10 out, I
did not ask her to do this. Okay.
This was the universe giving me a gift.
No.
Well, yes and no. Cielo Green the whole
time. Yes and no. It did not turn me on.
It did not turn me on sexually,
but it did turn me on socially because I,
I was going to post
this online and people are going to go
bananas. I was very excited. I was like,
I have to show people this is
going to give them great joy.
I think this is the part where
he started to lose it. Yeah,
mine. Yeah, I remember
Ryan, do you think she's alive now? Cause
that was like 2005 if you had a guess,
do you think that woman's Love
Paul subs every day? I'm sure
there's some Italians live forever.
Do you think God mother fuckers, they
live forever. That's good to know,
but that was a real moment for me. It was
a, it was a great, great moment for me.
I wish you had that on video though.
That would, yeah, it would be.
It would be awesome. D G
Galaxy s three via. Yeah,
but then she probably sue me. I wonder
if she knows the pictures out there.
I wonder if someone was like,
girl,
do you know to your pictures online
your titties out. You got to meet boss.
That ain't even me. My wig don't look
nothing like that. That is not that good.
That is not me, girl. I'm telling
you. That was a Veggie saying
did he has pictures of you. You got
your titty out and uh, meet Moss.
I'll be your hand and bitch. You look fat.
You look like big foot earthquake, gut.
Oh, that's a gut. I'm a person who doesn't
give a fuck. She doesn't give a fuck.
I didn't access the Dick. No, no. That's
all it takes. That's a real tip, bro.
Look at it at the tip
tip like that on a man,
a fake tits on men always look odd
and the nipples were never big enough.
And you know that that nipples the correct
size. That's the thing about trannies.
Oh, by the way, that's another.
Tell us what you know people are,
people are transphobic. Did you know that
Brian? That's a new issue. Transphobia.
I love the progressive's are going
after people that are trans phobic.
If you're making any jokes about trannies,
really even saying trannies. Yeah.
What did, did they have to joke
about? We need to be more sensitive.
I'm fascinated.
Did we already do we talk about buck
angel the last time we were on here?
I feel like we did. We might not
have talked to them all the time.
There's never enough talk about
buck angel. This is that we did a,
we did a show with him. Yes we did.
No, you did dip. Fucking let me,
I'm telling you the truth.
And we were in a Toronto,
Toronto,
Asia, just cute. It's in Canada. Um hmm.
It became a country boy. He confused
the shit out of people that were like,
really it was Toronto, a
country in Asia as well. Um,
is buck angel?
Well we, it was a, it
was called idea city,
which is like Ted talks and
it was a conference for,
it was really incredible. And you guys
played music? We did. Yeah, we were,
we were playing with our friend
Adam Cohen. We were his band,
so we weren't playing as honey honey,
which was kinda cool because I felt like
we were just a bunch of hired guns. Oh,
that's kind of fun. Right? Singing.
It was fun. Only when I go back and
watch the videos, I did not play well.
I'm not proud of my playing,
but I'm,
I'm fucking working on it and I've gotten
better. So for the record. But anyway,
we were,
the whole thing is Steve Martin's good.
He's really good. Oh my God, he's so good.
We got to see him in Nashville's. Yeah.
But, um, anyway, buck angel, the,
the conference that we were at,
I was a three day conference and the
theme was women and in all the facets of
like, it was going through
scientific evolution and you know,
in society and like there was anywhere
from Olympic gold medalists to doctors
and psychiatrists and lawyers and an
oceanographer. This incredible woman,
Doctor Sylvia Earle. I love her. Um,
and then they had two different
tranny's transvestites,
transphobia, angel trainings. I won't try
and tune man. Just be you. I don't know.
You can't call people twinks anymore.
Why not?
At the guy who's the head of the Bravo
for an advocate that goes ahead of Bravo.
He made it stop me, Joe.
He had apologized to the twink
neighborhood community. Let's see,
old Greg had a man Jina I
support him. Anyway, so,
so, so buck angel, look,
you should explain to people don't
know what the fuck fucking angel is.
A very famous transvestite, transsexual,
excuse me, who's a woman, um,
but is,
is almost as jacked as Joe Rogan and,
uh, just a massive frame of, of, uh,
of a man of a typical man, but
actually is a woman, you know,
porn. Right. And does porn and a
is married to a woman hall law,
but which makes me wonder,
does that make him a lesbian?
Well he does porn with girls or guys,
guys,
which I did the maybe girls
too, but I did, I did the,
I did myself and unsolid and I
was like, oh I'm, I'm curious.
Cause I was really fascinated
by buck angel talk to,
so I went online and I looked up some,
some bikinis a point and it was,
it was really,
it really kind of messed me up because
I saw him in the elevator the next day
cause he was, and I was just
like, Oh God, like I'm so,
I'm so confused. I'm just confused.
But I did it feel like gay porn.
What'd you feel like?
It was just like,
it was a total shaved
badge and it was just so,
it was like you, you see the top
frame, which is all like look, see,
he looks like a lumberjack. He's
got a goatee, he's tatted up,
he has huge muscles and he
lives his life as a man.
So I feel it's right to
call him him cause he,
I think that's what he prefers and he
was great. Like he was fucking cool.
I liked hanging out with them but like,
you know,
after I saw him getting pounded by dude
that look just like him into his vagina,
I was really,
oh there's buck on the right.
That is so crazy.
Look at him.
He's fucking huge.
That really does look like a fucking dude.
Big Guy. That's crazy. There's
Brian added that song by the way.
Did you really? Did you go
look for that bitch job?
If you go to that actual video, you will
not get that folks. Someone needs to meet
the mix. But yeah, that looks like
a big dude it. Yep. And there's no,
there's no d downstairs, but does he
have like a large classrooms? At least
it's, but also really, really excited
that he has this project going.
I just want to reach out to your kids and
let you know that I really had a tough
time and I was a kid. People didn't
understand me. People didn't get that.
I felt like a dye. It
was, I got teased. I got,
I was in fights constantly.
I was isolated. I didn't,
every time I reach out to,
I tried to commit suicide.
Oh God. Okay. Buck. You're bumming me out.
I wanted to watch. It sucks some Dick's.
I didn't want to watch you try.
You're acting like a little bitch.
No,
settle the fuck down.
You're insensitive.
This is more phobia.
Kieve people.
I'm going to throw up my vegan pizza now.
Oh, that's fine. And that's
it. Anyway, moving on.
Listen to it takes every kind of
people to make this world go round.
I think we learned that in the
70s and a buck angel. Good on Ya.
Go get that. So then there was
another transvestite that was x,
the same transsexual, excuse me, I'm using
the wrong, the wrong word. I'm invested.
It's just a pretender in my ignorance.
I was just a man in a dress.
I switched to really live a
sheltered life. When you go
and get you shit snipped.
Yes. When they move into the wonderful
world of people that made the commitment,
you know the name of them
need a store. How did, like,
so there's all these hormonal treatments
that they have to undergo and have to
get them every week or every month?
I think so. How do you afford that?
That's a good question. I wonder if, um,
people's insurance companies pay for it.
Oh boy. I bet they do. I bet. Let's find
out. Okay, let's Google. I bet they do.
I bet this is something that people have
been trying. There's a lot of trends
that are like really in a bad place and
they do not have the money to be happy
if they were just switch the gender.
And I think that as a community,
we should be doing that for branding.
Name this character.
I want to give my ultra progressive
Dick Wad. Give it, what's the name?
Like curl at whatever you
want. Cammie. Jill. Shelly.
Yeah.
A man named Shelly.
What am I looking for? I'm looking, I'm
looking for insurance companies exchange.
Okay. In sure ain't looking at
Buck's star Vagina. Alison. Guys.
This be good for everybody. I don't know
why I said that. What's wrong with you?
Try and keep up with our our
retardedness. Yeah, I think so. Well,
I think I'm feeling warm. Insurance
Company to pay for sex change. Bam.
What Queens woman trap for 34 years
in a man's body wins a battle with her
insurance company that balked at
paying for her sex change operation.
Wow. A Queens woman. I love
how they, first of all,
this is like really shitty journalism.
Really Shitty New York Daily News.
You don't say a Queen's woman trapped
in a man's body wins about it with your
insurance company. No, no, no, no.
You say transsexual man who became a
woman wins a battle with an insurance
company. You don't say someone trapped in
a man's body. How much maybe she's not.
Maybe hang out with it for a couple
of weeks and weeks and go, oh no,
this is just someone that's fucking
crazy, you know, isn't that possible? No,
you've made this like huge judgment
and painted this and um, you know,
a very biased way.
Although she does the glue to check.
There's gotta be some people out there
that have had actual sex changes and then
tried to go back. Jack, I'm sure.
I'm sure people were bummed out.
I remember this one,
this guy got really bummed out
because he couldn't come anymore.
He realized that he was
never going to call it.
That was what Nina story talked about.
Nina story is the famous transsexual
that was also at this conference,
the ever mentioned conference.
And um,
she had undergone how many
surgeries been? It was like, yeah,
like she was addicted to plastic
surgery and she had gone into like 60,
60 times under the needle. But she, she
did something that was really interesting.
She chose to have her body be a canvas
and she documented the whole change.
So she's,
she has videos and there is again,
Nina stories. Oh my God,
what have you done? And,
and it's funny because like you
look at her and she's just like this
unbelievable,
like she has a figure like Jessica Rabbit.
She looks like Jessica Rabbit.
Exactly. And it's, it's,
it's interesting. It's not,
it's just like,
it's a fascinating visual.
And she was really intense and she was
talking about her like her power and her
energy and she had this religion.
This is the wrong person.
There's another Nina's
story that's a singer
who sings. You fucking
ruined her life. Audio clips,
lyrics,
concert schedule photos,
a style incorporating pop
alternative rock, jazz and soul.
Say about it being used to have a dick.
Oh No,
I think it's a different person.
Different person. Did you find it? Oh,
buck angel. Oh, what is that? Oh No,
don't show me buck angels in large.
Cliteracy yeah.
Large. Yes. It's quite funky. Okay,
I'm going to look up on the
storage to do that, don't you?
It
makes me uncomfortable.
Why?
It makes it so don't be, don't be. But,
but that was what they both talked about.
It was that, and I don't blame them.
They said that they didn't want to go
with the full sexual transformation
because the propensity of losing your
orgasm with very high and he wants to lose
that, but how are you going to look
like a chick of you still have a duck?
You know? I mean, you're going to,
if you want to really be a woman
and pretend you're a woman,
you're going to have to give something up.
Are you going to have to give up Shannon
loads called a man Jina shooting loads.
Whenever I think of a woman, you know,
if a man wants to be considered a woman,
you can't have a deck. Okay? And
if you want us to call you Shane,
you know what's really funny,
you guys?
I was tempted to tell my
parents to listen to this,
listen to the previous to that
we did here, and I was like,
I bet today's going to be different
because I feel like everything's cool.
Educational. Really. You sure it's on
a story. So we are sorry.
Need a story. No story.
We're so sorry.
Please go support Nina story on iTunes.
Go buy her shit. We apologize, Nina.
Arceneaux I'm sure at your does.
He does look like a crazy Barbie
doll type thing. Oh Jesus Christ.
This silicone diaries.
Okay.
That's what's really amazing is
the body language cause it's still,
has she still moved like a dude?
Oh stop.
She sat down like,
well she said that because she said that
when she would open her legs to you,
that was her power energy coming
at you. Wow. Power Energy.
Her metaphorical whole,
goodness.
Goodness.
Joey Diaz and I were in Vegas once we,
a transsexual showed us the package with
Mrs. Reagan was there as well and she
got a chance to look at it too.
And Joey said it best.
He said it looked like a
bat with its mouth open.
It looked like someone had slammed and
apple core in this someone's cock cause
like you don't need that anymore.
Let me just sweep that bulge out and then
pull some ball skin over the hole and
like stitch, it looked like an
empty hole where a dick used to be.
Oh yeah dude.
And it's in the wrong spot to by the by.
Have you ever noticed a time we'll fake
vaginas and they're more towards the
front. Then the real vagina, you
know, real vagina is sort of tucked,
talked a little bit further
back. Vagina. Well Taste Jeffery,
a lot more salty.
What are you doing?
Criminal. But you could show
that. Well that wasn't real.
It just looked like it
was something sexual,
but it was just a dude
with his hand being silly.
Maybe you guys can fucking exercise the
horrible feelings and thoughts in this
room and his sweep them
out of here with a song.
He can't do that because this
conversation has gone dark, dark one.
Well somehow or another
we started out with dogs.
It was like dog world dogs,
people we in on each other.
I mean it's a quick,
but we can't,
we got the school shootings I
think led us to a dark place.
Then we tried to recover with some
humor and actual doc. I'm exhausted.
Crazy. Got a little crazy when you
guys brought up the buck cherry.
So buck also,
you guys are,
I mean
you guys know Buck Cherry.
I seen him don't know
him personally. Oh, okay.
You don't have like a buck cherry story.
I liked that cocaine song.
I don't even, I've never even done
cocaine, but that song is great.
It gets you got, yeah. Oh Man. He
loves the cocaine. You cocaine.
The new thing is, is
liquid cocaine. I know.
I've seen a lot of people having this
liquid cocaine where it's in like a,
like a nose spray thing and you just
spray it in your nose. No, wait. Yeah.
That is crazy. And so it just looks
like no nasal looks like you're doing.
Like you just cleaning your nose
out. You're just doing it. Oh my God.
These people just carry them around in
their purse and he was like, it's crazy.
And I guess it's better also for you.
It's healthy.
It's like cigarettes and good for you.
It's like the cigarette with a
fucking Stephen Dorff commercial.
Guys, let's take back our
ability to do coke and public.
Say Back our freedom. Have you seen
that commercial, Stephen Dorff?
Oh my God,
it is possibly.
It possibly broke the Douche scale.
It might've broken the Douche scale.
Brion pull it up please.
While we're waiting for beautiful
Suzanne to urinate. This is a video.
Blue cigarettes,
Stephen Dorff commercial blue cigarettes.
It is easily the Douchey has
commercial in the history of the world.
He's in black and white. Okay.
And he smoked it an e cigarette.
Take us freedom back, man.
Why was, what's his thing?
How can we know Stephen Dorff?
He's, he was in bleed. Okay.
Was that his breakout role? Not As,
I mean you did a lot of movies but,
but he was in blade.
I mean he was the fucking head
vampire and blade from there on.
It's been a downhill slide. And to the
point where no disrespect and he's like,
well, goodbye fear factor guy. We're
just talking about reality here.
Scientists don't get upset.
Know building.
I probably would have done that commercial
to that cigarette commercial if they
paid me enough.
Who knows?
But once you see it, he just like, whoa.
You gotta be really unaware to write this,
to ask someone to do it.
Forget about him. Look
at this. Oh wait, thesis.
I'm tired of being a walk.
Brian, stop with the music.
Walking Astrid.
I'm tired of feeling guilty every
time I want to light up negative one.
I'm tired of being a walking
asterik negative too.
I'm tired of feeling guilty every time
I want to light up. I'm Steven door.
I've been a smoker.
Hold on. Pause the Suzanne
messages. You got to see this cause.
Hurry up and sit down. The Stephen Dorff
cigarette commercial. Have you seen this?
No, I haven't seen. I've seen the ads.
It's the Douchey is commercial. Oh,
you broke your leg.
It's the Douchey as commercial
and the history of the human race.
I don't think there's been
a douchey or commercial.
It's for Stephen Dorff
for electric cigarettes.
Okay. Juan, who? This? I'm tired of
being a walking ashtray negative too.
I'm tired of feeling guilty every time
I want to light up. I'm Steven door.
I'd been a smoker for 20 years and I
just found the smarter alternative blue.
He says,
blue lets me enjoy smoking without it
affecting the people around Malibu,
not tobacco smoke.
That means no ash and best hall PLO.
Offensive Odor.
We could smoke at the basketball game.
If you want to and how about not having
to go outside every 10 minutes when
you're in a bar with your friends.
The point is you can smoke blue
virtually anywhere. Oh, that's so dumb.
Oh, I don't like us then. I don't
want to get it. [inaudible] I like,
I like when we take our freedom.
I like how it looks or play.
He paused away, looked at what?
Stop it with the music. You fuck. Okay,
look it up. I'm just like looking cool.
Black and white holds it out believable.
It broke to Douche bag scale.
It literally broke the Douche scale. It's
black and white for no fucking reason.
There's no reason for that.
It's an artistic choice.
I'm going to do this commercial, but I
want it to be already know fuck. I want,
I want to look like Jack Caraway
and to be honest with you,
I smoke electronic cigarettes because
there's nothing wrong with small then I
wouldn't,
I don't like to tell anyone or do it
in public because I'm unembarrassed.
But like I,
I'm satisfied because I'm not smoking
regular cigarettes cause I love them,
but they're bad for me. Well, I don't
think electronic cigarettes, that was,
that was one of the Douchey is
things I've ever been. I'm, and I'm,
I feel like I need to take, I need
to take a time out. No, listen,
I support the idea of electric cigarettes.
It's not what the idea of electric
cigarettes, I totally support it.
But that approach,
the cool guy on the beach,
someone should get up there and
be like, hey, I do this. But it's,
it's pretty clean image that they're
trying to portray is like this man who's
like rugged with his,
like his stubble by the ocean
with like a Siemens jacket on.
You know? I mean, he has this
fucking Jack Kerouac look to him.
Like he's going to go write the great
American novel and he's just so cool to be
around. Goes to the local bar and
they all know him by name. You know,
buck angel like to smoke
cigarettes on them. Meanwhile,
I'd like comes up the puck angels
pregnant, Stephen Dorff loved
child. What if fucking you'll
go. I don't, I don't know.
I don't know if it can work
anymore. Yeah. They would come out.
It would be dragons.
That's where dragons come from.
The societies figuring out how to turn
a man to a woman than a guy fucks it and
then it gets pregnant. A dragon is born.
I think I saw that in game of Thrones.
Where is it? Chemo Thrones coming out in
March. It's isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. Ooh,
you just made me excited about March.
I can't wait.
[inaudible] the end of the
world can't come. It's, you
know what title I honestly,
I'm going to take back what I said
before, but what? I think we're okay.
I think we're okay. I really
do. We're okay with just
the aliens are coming. Well,
I think the only is already here. I
know. If you get in an isolation tank,
they'll talk to you. Did you? There's
that show. This is, I fucking love this.
I haven't seen it.
I don't even know.
What's the show called on the neighbors
or something where it's about aliens and
they, they, they come to
life. No, they come to earth.
That's what the dude from me are.
I'm not sure what all I know is Mike.
My friend told me about it, and I
forgive me if I miss miss quote myself,
but the show is about these aliens come
to earth and it looked like people and
they don't have very,
uh,
they don't have like substantial up to
date information on how to integrate
themselves into the human society. They
have this like sports almanac from 1985,
so they all give themselves names like
Jackie Joyner Kersee and like Larry Bird
and Kareem Abdul Jabbar,
and it's like a six year old white kid
and his name is Kareem Abdul Jabbar.
I could be totally wrong.
I've, I've never seen the show,
but my friend was telling me about
it and I thought that was funny.
That's kind of funny.
Yeah.
That,
that's how the aliens come and six year
olds at pretend to be black athletes.
Dude, I would, yeah, that's how I do
it. Confused the fuck out of everybody.
Uh, before you guys get started, I
gotta give a shout out to the float lab.
The float lab in Venice, California,
and the premiere isolation tank, uh,
people builders in the country,
they're there on the west coast.
If you're ever in California, if you're
in San Francisco, oh, take a flight down.
Trust me. You need to see what these
guys are doing there. They have like,
they're taking isolation
tanks to the next level.
They just installed a new one in
my basement this week. It's crazy.
You got to come see it.
We've got to make a new video and
we'll that last video you, hey,
let's make a new one because this new
ones insane. And uh, I want to, um,
take care of them. If you, uh, if you're
in Venice or anywhere near it and you can,
you can get there.
I think it's only like 40 bucks for an
hour and a half or something like that.
They're very reasonable and without a
doubt they have the best equipment on the
planet earth.
This new one they put in my basement
is eight feet long and six feet wide to
frank. Go in there, check it.
Yeah, you get get up a group.
You get to have a party in
that bitch. Get Buck, buck,
buck angel and Buck Cherry both together.
If buck angel got
pregnant from Buck Cherry
might be the apocalypse
if you had to be in the,
in the isolation tank with all of
them and Steven door. Yeah. Wow.
Y'all crazy bitch bitch.
Fuck so good. A lot of top
of it.
Trying to be cool by the beach man. I'll
think what you're doing is cool at all.
It's isolated. It's together.
Good for electronic cigarette.
Try to be in a guilty but lighten up and
you could light up at a basketball game.
Cause you know me man.
I like to go to the game.
Oh hang out with the guys have a beer.
Why does your man vaginas
smelled like Jay Moore?
What exactly the chain
smell like?
Bookshare archangel
by boat by the way. I'm a
buck cherry fan. Don't get it.
Don't get it twisted right.
I love Buck Cherry.
That crazy bitch song.
When I think about my ex girlfriends,
like all of them that they could play
like all my memories of every check that I
dated until I was like 26 and throw
them together with a buck cherry song.
That crazy bitch song. Just all the my
memories of every crazy one of them.
Splice them all together.
So respect to Buckcherry
and respect to buck angel.
Fuck it man. If you really feel like
you were a dude, fuck it. Get in there.
So I know you've done a great job of
looking exactly like a dude. You know,
if you were in Jujitsu class,
I wouldn't want to roll with you.
You look quite big.
I have to deal with that
kind of horsepower. Would
you shrimp out? I will do.
I'll hit escape. Try to hip
escape. You know what we did on,
on a Saturday night this
past weekend inside trim,
we went to an amateur wrestling night
in Nashville. It was Friday night.
That sounds awesome. Those
things. That was our second one.
We went to one of the most
people in this past year,
like three months ago by default.
And it is a,
it is an unbelievable thing. It's a
social experiment, right? It really is.
And it's a, for some reason
around like really big dudes.
I like something happens to me where
like coagulating I think it is,
I swear to God because I like,
okay,
one time I was in Las Vegas
with my whole family by the way,
because we all like to drink and gamble.
Um,
and we were at the Rio and
it was Christmas time and
all of a sudden all these
Chippendale's came out with
Santa Claus and I was like,
oh my God. And I got pulled onto the
stage and I couldn't do anything except go
cause they picked me up
in there just to know big.
And I just kept touching their arms and
I was like, oh my God. Did you add your,
your hormones start firing time.
I'm a real, like I'm a real, I'm
a real personality kind of girl.
So the whole thing.
I think just the actual visual is so
it's such a shock to my system of like a
big dude. Right? He's like picking me
up in his shirts off and he's very,
he's hairless and greasy. But will
you willing to let it go and like,
except the fantasy. Oh yeah.
It was a total fantasy.
Total Magic Mike on his mother
fucker. Yeah, I mean, and I dunno,
in my mind he's probably hung
like a field mouse and I was fine.
I'm just in your mind, rationalize
it. I was like, yeah, there's nothing.
This is, this is all wrong.
It's all wrong. But there's
some in your personality,
the big dude,
I mean the big dude thing
is such a crazy phenomenon.
So you could go into a parallel dimension
which could never be accessed again,
and those Chippendale's guys
could just run a train on you,
but no one would ever know.
You'll be cool with that.
As long as he can just let it go for like,
why it's not even a real,
it doesn't even exist.
And after it's over you go right back
to the moment we thought up that idea.
You're the only one with memory.
It's all good.
You know if we had some deep talks and
they held me afterwards I think I'd be
cool with that.
Tough to find deep talks and the
Chippendale's guys and probably a lot of,
and those guys are listening
to this podcast right now.
Right now they're gone bro. Okay. If
you were in my shoes, fucking magic.
Mike fucking got me going.
I was into it but anymore I digress.
And he wore,
we were at the,
we were at the amateur wrestling night
and there was one of those dudes and it
was like he was not
obviously he wasn't great.
A top choice muscle meat for me but he
was really interesting and there was
three personality, I disagree, but
grade a top choice of muscle meat.
How do you define that? Do
you have like, it's all like,
but you're looking for like a
Brock Lesnar type character.
Like what is your grade A's?
Brock Lesnar, Brock Lesnar,
a former UFC heavyweight champion.
So I need some help with like
the Russian dude and rocky. Yeah.
He looks like a viking.
Like he looks like come here on a
boat with a fucking sword in his hand.
[inaudible] page.
I'd probably cut your head off
while he's, while he's fucking
you. It'd be like an experience.
This is so bad and I believe I was going
to tell my parents to listen to this,
to Christ. They don't. I'm sorry honey.
We really apologize if you're
listening right now. We didn't.
We didn't mean to paint her and such an
unfavorable light. This is all just play.
We're applying.
This is Internet Haymont and real life.
I would never talk to
your daughter like that.
She's a beautiful human being and I
respect it very much, but on the podcast,
we've got to take our shots
for entertainment. Okay.
And that's where the whole gang bang
run a train Chippendales in the parallel
dimension thing came from.
I don't want that to happen.
I don't think Suzanne wants
that to happen either.
But afterwards where they say,
I don't think anybody knew what to do
because I was just like, wow. I was like,
I was high. I mean they picked me
up. Right. Is that feel good though?
Kinda kinda tall.
That doesn't happen very often.
I can manhandle you women want that shit.
That's your DNA crying out.
So I do. Doesn't want the opposite
of God doesn't want to check her.
Carries them upstairs.
Like we'll tell fuck for girl picks you
up and carries you upstairs to fuck you.
You're like, okay. You already
defeated how many guns that happen.
I don't think it's ever happened to me
yet, but this is Rogan. Life was young.
Things can happen.
People can you crazy?
Yeah, but a man doesn't want
a woman, Karen. Right. Have
you ever had to do carry,
you met a girl rather carry you Ben?
I'm not in a sexual sense. Maybe. Uh,
just around town. Just hopped on
a few backs, I think. Wow. Yeah.
That's,
you gotta be really confident.
Someone has a fall backwards and
we'll get back to that stuff. I have.
Especially when you grab people,
grabbing your ankles, holding you,
and two more of your friends. He's a big
guy to more your friends. Yeah, he's,
he's locked up three people body to dot.
Although the w the lady was on
the small side, she was very tiny.
What's the small side? A
hundred pounds. She probably,
she probably like a five tour.
That's a lot.
Something like that to add to a duty
dude. He's like your seven foot, bro. Wow.
There's, there's some big humans
out there. It happened. Honey.
Honey, what are you gonna play for
us? What do you want to do? Excuse me?
What do Radiohead. Okay, and here we go.
Yeah. No sadness. Cover,
uplift. Obviously.
This is a song by Radiohead that we wrote.
You Ready?
Okay.
We're just going to go with it yet.
We'll still Betty. Yeah. Is that okay?
Is that okay bro? Bro,
Bro, here we go. Bitches.
One more time too.
Yeah.
Oh,
used to be all right.
What happened?
The cat gets show Tom.
Wow.
What happened?
Fifties Ah,
awesome.
Then you cook this.
That was fucking,
that was really cool. Very cool.
Very different for you guys.
It's weird. I love it. I love it.
That's a really interesting guy.
Take on that song too. Yeah. You know,
we, we haven't played that as a duo,
which was oh really? Well we
played with my roommate, uh,
this very talented musician,
Ben Lewis and he played,
we did it a little trio style and
he played mandolin and things.
So it was kind of,
it really sounded bluegrass.
Is it still scary if you guys make,
when you think like you guys
performed so much together?
I would think you have almost like a sort
of an ESP and it comes to doing a song
together and you know how to like
ebb and flow with each other.
Does it like when you like a song like
that we haven't done as a duo before and
you were just doing it because
you don't want it to suck you?
No, but I mean, especially if you're
going to cover a fucking radio head song,
you want to, you want to like do it some
justice. I think that was like a B minus.
What'd you think? Oh that was great. Shut
the fuck up. Don't judge yourself. Okay.
There you go. Right? I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. You sounded really good
on the radio. Had they release all their
shit online, right? Did they do that?
They do. They do both now. They did.
Well they did at least one of their
albums on I'm to, yeah, I think
they were the first big band
to say name your price. Yeah.
Really? Yeah. Oh Wow.
So how do they do that?
They just say like you put up a paypal
account or something like that so you can
give us a buck or you can give us,
yeah,
that makes you think if we do that we'll
make millions of dollars to quite there
yet. I don't know. Maybe we should try.
Do you guys feel a buildup?
I feel like your crowds are getting larger
or your Twitter followers are getting
more. You're getting more
attention. Do you feel it?
We're kind of cruising right now
because we're working on this record,
so we haven't been going out much. We
haven't torn that much and it's, it's,
it's not a lot way. It is a low cause
we're not, we're not touring. You're just,
there isn't the end creating new stuff.
Yeah. Yeah. Do you, um, when you do that,
how do you, do you take time off
the road and you just like say,
okay we have to set aside x
amount of weeks. Like how do you,
how do you do it when you
decide you're going to,
we keep trying to set deadlines. No,
we're setting deadlines. Um, so we're,
we're going to be recording by
late February, but we still,
we have a lot of work to do.
You know,
we have a lot of writing that we haven't
done yet and we've been, it's so funny.
Last time we were here we were doing the
Kickstarter stuff and in between we've
been making all the rewards,
all the people who donated.
Oh, the videos. So Haikus, man.
I tell you something that's hilarious.
It's been, it's been really, really good
fun and a lot of work.
But like the,
the actual, it's just the two of us,
like nobody's helping us with it,
which is really, really the
truth. And like each person,
like half, like, you know, 90% of them,
we don't know who they are and that it's
such a cool feeling. Like, you know,
someone gave us like people giving us
$500 or even $25, whatever the case is,
like a really amazing feeling. And then
like to write them, they're Haiku and,
and so like stuttering.
Well it's, it's really cool.
I hear what you're saying. It was
fun, but we're almost done. Um,
and we've got a couple of shows, you
know, things like that here in there.
But really we're just writing.
It's really cool.
And you know,
these people were always going to
have this connection with you now,
you know? Yeah. It has been a good thing
to see. See all these names. Now we,
we know the names too, like addresses
we can find. You know where you live.
It's really bad ass when
you stop and think about it.
I just need to sleep on your
couch. It's so unusual. You know,
I really stop and think about it. How
often does, does a band get to do that?
I mean the rolling stones
never got a chance to do that
when they were coming up.
You know who gets chance to do that?
No,
but they hung out with the hell's
angels and no big deal. Is that okay?
That's a substitute we need to do is we
need to get a motorcycle gang behind us
and I think that's just like straight
to the tippy top that gets like people
stabbed.
You gotta be
careful with that shit. I mean,
it's not so bad. Just kidding.
I got
jokes through.
This is kind of a weird,
maybe terrible thing I got through the
airport. Security with a knife. Yes.
Somebody else just told me the
exact same thing I did. I had,
I realized he was in my Jack and I said,
fuck I do you carry a knife. 40
domestic. The gift. You're getting crazy.
It's a gift from out of town.
Maybe I have to shit on the fucker.
When you're a jet, you're a jet
for life. Exactly. I will snap.
Switched plays making a comeback. Yes.
I carry a knife on me all the time.
Do you really? Yeah. Wow.
It's it, you know what, like when your
package is a really hard to open to them,
you walk to your car,
you want to open something,
you got a little thread on your code.
Just listen.
Don't think I don't appreciate it.
If I was a chick that'd be armed as fuck.
You know,
I,
I didn't really think about it as
much until I moved to Nashville and I,
I'm alone a lot of the time. So it's like,
nevermind. I'm fine. I'm totally armed.
I have a big dog. It's just
pulled their pants off. Dude,
I'm fucking a lot of time.
When did you start?
If from the beginning, oh, Suzanne,
please stop.
That's my giant only redneck
that sees you at the supermarket.
I want to fight to the death if I have
to, you know, like how your role, oh,
you gotta do what you gotta
do. It's getting hard. Cool.
Living in Nashville is a
better, worse, different.
I, I'm going to say better.
Better in the sense that,
uh, from, uh, you know, uh,
I'm here to play music vibe.
Like you get so much more for your dollar.
It's a very affordable town.
There's incredible musicians on every
corner that are welcoming and inspiring
and helpful.
And like we,
we have all these friends that help us
with like just getting integrated and we,
um, I really like it. It's funny, I was,
I was telling Red van earlier, he's like,
how are you doing? And I was
like, you know, I'm great
and I love La. I really do.
But like the minute I got on the
10 and I was stuck in traffic,
I was in a foul mood really? Well,
yeah. I just like, I wanted to get here,
I want him to go pick up band across
town. And like, it was just, it was funny,
like it took so long to get
here. I left at 1230. Wow.
And I dunno, there's just something
about Nashville that I really, the, our,
our productivity, like your energy
you have, I have more energy.
I go to the YMC a like four times a week,
I mean things or look at this,
it's happening. So you have
more time, more time. Much
more time. But why is that?
I'm used to so much slower there just
in general. And it's a smaller town.
There's not as many people. We know fewer
people you can get around easier. Yes.
Ben Lives like a mile and a half
for me, which is nice. So again,
you guys are moving to new place.
Why don't you move right next
door to each other. You're crazy.
Why not create such a little community?
Well you are right next door to
each other. Yeah, I mean we're, I,
I couldn't tell you the last time I want
a day without seeing it like a whole
day. How's that feel? It feels
great. I think you're really great.
I think you're really funny and you're
so smart and talented and good looking
full on. Wow. Great Body.
Okay. You guys rolling?
Beautiful. She's got ugly. Do you have to
resist that? Do you have to resist the,
I mean you think we should
talk about it for a long
time to have to resist romantic urges?
I'm just,
no conversation is going gay these days.
No need to have this conversation.
Ben's revisiting his life.
It's odd though to, to have a,
a man woman sort of equal partnership
like this in a band that works and nobody
winds up cam pregnant. Oh my God,
God, I'm so not ready for that.
You know? I mean you guys are like
bandmates really good friends.
It's a,
that's a weird position for a man or a
woman to be like really good friends,
isn't it?
In this day and age it's very happy.
You know,
it's diff.
It's difficult in a lot of
different ways because you know,
for the significant others that we date.
Yeah.
That's like a, that's a big
one too. Cause we're so close.
I mean we and creativity together
is a very intimate thing. So, um,
you know, it's, it's a,
it's a rough road being a musician in
general because like you either date
someone in your band or you date someone
not in your band that you never see or
you're with someone that you see
every day. There's like this like
fine line. Do you ever, did you ever date
a guy? He's like, the fucking Ben Guy.
Never know. And that would be
ridiculous. That would be like, oh,
why would I want to date someone who
didn't like my best friend and be like,
yeah,
unless he was a Chippendale,
I might make some reparations.
Yeah, she was a child.
Just those guys from that night.
If you can just relay it to be short
lived relationship, let me tell you.
Oh listen, that's what you're looking
for. What are you trying to do?
Trying to fix the world. Trying to have
a good time. Okay. What are you gonna do?
Establish a Topia.
I start a new community.
Know you can get your freak out
with a bunch of fucking shave dudes.
That's the problem.
A little baby oil and a big party.
The smell of Suntan lotion
in the air, right? God,
it's so funny. Like shavers, all
of the fellows. How does that,
I'm white as goat cheese. This
is just like, it's amazing.
I couldn't get a tan to say my
life. No, I've tried it didn't,
it didn't work out well.
Nothing. We're gone burn. I
burn. Yeah. You have dark hair?
I do, yeah. What is your
nationality? Italian. I'm a,
I'm a papa side and my mom is native
American, Indian and European, Huh. Yeah.
So I'm going to live forever and
be an alcoholic. Hello. Kidding.
It was not the case like the,
do you find it runs in your community?
Absolutely. Yeah. I mean gift court, first
of all, who's family? I want to know.
It doesn't have alcoholism
but boring people.
But I mean it's, it's true. Like
every, every culture has their
physical relationship to it. Um,
genetically speaking. Um,
and I believe that the,
I'm a lightweight as much as
I love to drink. Like I'm,
I'm kinda good after two drinks,
I'm pretty warm. I, my voice,
my gets louder. Um, you know,
I start taking my clothes off.
That was a lie. Um, uh, in,
in the most fucking classy kind of way.
Bros,
that's all I know about that for the most
class. You kind of way period. But um,
anyway, yeah, I hope, I hope that I
said that well and it was not offensive.
Do you find is easy to
make friends in Nashville?
You guys like meeting
people and enjoy it warm?
It's an unusual town. Isn't
it? Yeah. And it's so, it's,
I never realized how huge Ellie was until
you go to Nashville and it really is a
small town.
Like we'd go out,
we were there two weeks and he'd go out
and you're seeing people that should
know,
um,
and you can get across town in 15 minutes
and everybody's just kinda wants to
hang. It's like a big sitting on the
porch beer drinking community. Yeah.
It's like,
I think that when towns get too big and
there's a lot of great things about La,
there's a lot of,
I mean there's so many great
restaurants are so many places to go.
All my friends live here. I love
La, but I really like smaller towns.
I really loved living in Boulder.
I really love Portland. I know,
I really love Nashville, Nashville span
ass. And there's like, um, a better vibe.
There's like, like, oh, the
frequency in the air is less intense.
It's not death metal. It's like fucking
piano music. You know what I mean?
It's like you can relax a little, like
the frequency of the actual city itself.
You go to New York. Okay. New York is,
it's red line. Everywhere you go on,
there's too many people.
No way to avoid that. It's a
crazy fucking town. You could,
you could take you an hour to drive
across that stupid island, you know,
a whole hour easily, easily, which
should take you a minute, you know,
just take you one minute,
I tell you.
So that kind of stress is going to
definitely affect people socially and you
don't get that in like a place like
Nashville. And that in itself is better.
And I ended, it feels like the pace of
everything is slower so you can get more,
I dunno if you take advantage of it,
you can get more accomplished because
there's not this constant scurrying,
but you feel like you have to, or at least
I haven't felt like I had to do in La.
It was like get to hear, get to
hear. Good to hear, good to hear.
And then nothing would actually
come with any of these. No,
I feel that I feel that
constant scoring you. You know,
I've had friends like Eddie Bravo,
he used to live in west Hollywood and he
liked living in West Hollywood because
he felt like when he lived there the
pace was like a faster pace because
everyone is doing things.
It made him feel like you had
to get up and get things done.
That's the last shit I need.
You know, I do not want it.
Well it's kind of like a,
you have to get up and get things done
and then you can't get there on time
cause you have to wait. That's
a difficult thing to, to digest.
Do you guys do any wean covers?
No.
We talked about piss up a
rope last time we were here.
Where did she when you were two cheese go.
Oh that's great.
I love cheese. I love cheese.
You know it's a sad thing about
cheese.
Oh no Joe don't tell him fucking
country people are not allowed to use
unpasteurized milk to make cheese.
You have to pasteurize the
milk and homogenize it and
boil it down and kill all
the stuff that makes the cheese tastes
good. You ever have cheese in Europe?
Kind of cheese in France.
You have some non homogenized cheese
and France from an old like the
cheesemaker.
Some mother fucker really
knows what they're doing and
you can get it in America.
I mean don't get me wrong,
there's places and we used to
get some really delicious cheese.
Um,
there's a place in Beverly hills,
it's like it's a straight cheese
place and I know they probably,
it's probably like a Cuban cigars sort of
a thing. Like you can get Cuban cigars,
be got to know people,
they're going to know you first and then
they slip you the non homogenized non
pasteurized cheese access in Los Angeles.
Do you ever have a raw milk?
Do you ever drink raw milk?
It's delicious and it's so good.
It's just okay. Raw milk with
cookies. You cannot go wrong. Warm.
A little curt with some bad ass fucking
straight from the teeth getting on the
lap of an elderly man. Cubic cares if
you get some bad ass cookies. Okay.
Some really good like Nestle's tollhouse
type bitches. Like what does that,
what does that would,
that place of the airport where you
go to [inaudible] house, cookies.
Botches type of honeypot. What is
the fucking no nuts in them on the,
um, those cookies. There
was like the, there's like a
fucking famous cookie chain.
There are amazing cookies. Got,
I can't remember famous name now.
Older neighbors are pretty good, but
there's like cookies. He get like,
they're always at the middle. Mrs
Field. Yesterday you go Mrs. Fields,
take a few of those
chocolate chips and you know what?
I'm going to find them as this
fields in this area in Pasadena,
and we're going to go there after this
fucking show. I need some cookies.
You can't go. You gotta get the Hollywood
look. What's happening? How are you like,
oh my, my comedy special comes out
tomorrow, Ladies and gentlemen. Uh,
tomorrow it comes out on Joe rogan.net.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
it's a available, we were having a
problem with the Amazon thing. It's, um,
it was supposed to be ready today,
but it's not.
So hopefully it will be ready by tomorrow,
but if not the paypal thing,
we'll definitely still be ready.
I like it to be ready with Amazon.
So you could do that one click,
which is awesome by the way.
I'm a huge Amazon one click proponent.
Um,
so it'll be on Joe rogan.net.
It'll be there too.
That's what it's gonna look
like. You know, you got to
enter in all your nonsense.
And the, uh, the special something that
I, I paid for it entirely myself, uh,
Louis C K style. I did a
essentially exactly what he did. Um,
I'm releasing it for five bucks.
Uh,
I think what he did like by setting
that price, it's like really smart.
I think it's really cool.
And you know, Louise,
one of the best comics in the country,
why would you ask for more? Don't put,
don't be plants and how to stop that
shit. I know what it is. It's my show,
but it's available, uh, tomorrow. Um,
and then there's like a whole
thing that I paid for it.
And please don't steal it.
You know,
of course certain people are
going to steal it. You're
going to, but uh, it's, uh,
I think it's a reasonable
price. I think, uh,
I think this sort of model like what we
were talking about with Radiohead would
they did and allowing people to pick
their own, I think stop playing my shit,
dude. I wasn't playing city. It's
kind of cool to look at the quality.
It's dare you know,
it's great.
Positive image video did it at the same
people that produce the UFC shows. Um,
and my friend Anthony Giordano,
he's the director of it and he's the one
who did my last one talking monkey's in
space too. And uh, we, you know,
I'm real excited to do it this
way for a couple reasons. One,
I think it's the best
way to distribute things,
to distribute them online and to do it
directly to your fans instead of having
to go through comedy central or
any of these other, for comic,
like to have an outlet to
release your stuff. There's,
there's only a few options.
You could do an HBO thing or
a showtime thing or I know,
and like unfortunately you have to
actually sit down with people when you do
that and they have to decide what you,
what they like about your material,
what they don't like and that
shit, that shit is whack. Okay.
That is like the worst thing about being
a comedian is when you go to release
your stuff and there's other people that
have a say or want to have a saying in
the actual content. It's
crazy. It's that. It's the,
they're the dumbest conversations I've
had. People get upset at the dumbest shit.
It's, it's really, it's, it's mind
boggling and it's unnecessary.
And I think one of the things that
is really important about art is a,
whether it's,
um,
a standup comic or someone who writes
something or whatever it is. I love,
uh,
an individual's unique point of view.
I love seeing the way a person
puts it together. You know,
whether it's perfect or not, if
it comes from you. I liked that.
I liked knowing that you
wrote all your jokes.
I like knowing that you thought all
these thoughts that you printed all those
words. I want to be connected with
your, your thoughts, your creativity,
your consciousness.
And the only way to do that is for a
person to release their own shit. Period.
You know,
whether it's a band released their own
shit or a comedian to release their own
shit. As soon as you have some executive
type characters interfering with your
creative process, you're fucked.
You know, you just are, they,
that's not what they're supposed to be
doing. But when they can, they will,
they get their dirty little
greasy fingers, all of your shit,
and they fuck it up inevitably. And uh,
I guess that's not necessary anymore.
Um, because of, uh, this podcast,
we've essentially cut out doing most radio
shows. I mean a occasionally do radio,
but it's not like every week. Like
I used to have to do it. It's,
I don't have to do as
many different interviews.
You can talk directly to the
people that enjoy what you do.
And this is, these are
crazy times, you know,
this podcast alone has
changed my life chains.
Brian's life changed Ari's alive.
Duncan's life.
Joey's life changed all our lives.
We're, we're in a weird place right now.
And,
uh,
I think the only smart thing to do is
just keep going in the same direction.
That's why I got this new studio set up
and that's why were releasing things on
line like this.
And that's why we're all touring and
we're all continuing to write material.
And you're special by the way,
is outright now.
You could actually buy it this second,
right? This is right second. Yeah.
I'm not supposed to say that because
they're trying to get everything in order,
especially get the Amazon Shit corrected.
But if you want to get crazy,
go ahead and buy it. Download it. It's
supposed to be up. Yeah, I mean, again,
like I said it and don't say sorry. You
didn't know. How did you know? Uh, yeah,
but tomorrow it's official.
So wait for tomorrow if you'd like
fucking opening up your presence in the
morning. If you want to list those
dudes is still believes in Santa.
Wait until tomorrow. Okay. If not, yeah,
you can go fucking get it right now.
Five Bucks, please don't steal it.
Okay. I paid for the shit constantly.
More than a hundred thousand dollars
to film. It's very expensive, but,
well you did professional style.
Yeah, no, I didn't fuck around.
And we did it at the
Tabernacle in Atlanta,
which is a beautiful historic theater.
It's an amazing, amazing theater.
And uh, it was important for, I haven't
been to Atlanta and a couple of years,
so it was important to do it somewhere
where I hadn't been for a while to cover,
you know, to I, I don't,
I hate getting emails from people
like wouldn't fuck you coming back to
Vancouver. Trust me, I want to come
back to Vancouver. I just don't,
I haven't had a chance. So that
was an Atlanta sort of a situation.
So it was really cool to be able to
do it in Atlanta. And Atlanta is a,
does not get enough credit.
That is a bad ass fucking town.
I love Atlanta and it's one of the like
the most diverse like racially diverse
towns,
Atlanta's miles places where you see
like a lot of black dudes wearing suits.
Like a lot of like eight or shoes. Yeah,
like expensive clothes and you know,
driver like it's weird thing.
It's like there's a lot of like
black professionals in Atlanta.
It's like the uh,
the level of interaction between
white people and black people.
It's way higher in Atlanta.
And uh, that's, that's a
fucking real problem with La.
You know, I'll, La is first of all like
kind of segregate and second of all,
it's such a car culture
that people don't really,
it's not like on the subways in New York,
people will mingle black people mixed with
white people. Everybody gets together,
people from different, all sorts of
different economic groups are altogether.
That's in La.
That's not the case in la.
There's like a lot of haves and have nots.
It's a lot of separation
and everyone's driving,
so no one's like on a train
with a bunch of young kids.
So it's different sort of a vibe. I think
we miss out because of that. You know,
the idea that, you know,
he'd get a little more,
a little less crime that way and you know,
it's a little safer that way,
but you miss out on a little bit of the
whole experience of being a human and
Atlanta. It's a slot, a lot
of mixing going on. It was
cool. You know, I liked it.
So a lot of black guys with white
checks, a lot of that. So a lot of that.
I saw her, a bunch of white dudes
of black chicks too. It was,
it was an interesting place.
I dig Atlanta,
but it was a really cool place to
my special jackals. Great. Yeah,
it's pretty dope.
And that's the name of the special,
it's live from the tabernacle because a,
I'm not that creative and I
couldn't come up with a better name.
That's all I had in my wheel
house. I searched, I found nothing.
I decided to just release it. So talk from
talking monkey's in space to live from
the last one I ran out of my good names.
Do you do once he released his specialty,
stopped doing that material? Why? Yeah.
I mean maybe a rare occasion
if someone yell something out,
I will do it just for fun,
you know? But it's over. Yeah.
I've got to let that shit go. Move on
to the next material. That's why, uh,
first of all it's what people are like,
why did it take so long to release this?
Because we filmed it on
four 20 in the April.
So part of it took that time because I
had a new website that just went live
last week and it takes a long time to
get like a professional website design
company to build like
exactly what you want.
And you know that just the website traffic
has been so crazy that it's gotten to
a point where I needed something that
was like a little bit more robust and a
little bit more functional
and then incorporating the
podcast into it. And we're,
we're working on a totally new podcast
website now and that's like the next step.
But it's, it's the whole
podcast thing is just, it's,
it's gotten so out of control. It's
almost like, I don't know how Brian,
if you feel about the same way I do,
but I always feel like we're like on a
fucking little boat on top of some crazy
wave. And we're like, Whoa,
what do we need to do? We need
for a fucking rafts. Okay,
let's get rafts. You know, like when
we, when we buy shit for the studio,
it's always like, what do we need?
Oh, I need more of this shit.
We need more of that shit.
And it just seems to be kind of grown on
its own and we're just kind of keeping
up with it. You know, this is
a part of it. So, you know,
these shows that we do, uh, when
I, whenever I ask people like,
how many guys listen to the
podcast? It, what about a year end?
It was about 50% and now it's like a
hundred percent. Now it's crazy. And, uh,
we're having the fucking time of our
lives. I just want to tell you guys,
as much as you, people are
enjoying it, we get these emails,
we get these tweets and texts messages.
I get these emails every day that tell
people or are people telling us rather
that the podcast has changed their life
and change the way they think about
things and the conversations we've had
with people like Dennis Mckenna yesterday,
I talked to a guy today who told me
listen to it five times already came out
yesterday. You know, it's like, it
was such a crazy fucking conversation.
We are just as you are, we're growing
with these conversations as well.
There's no other way.
Brian and I would have had the opportunity
to sit down with all these people and
have these conversations with them.
They wouldn't just be willing to come
meet us somewhere and sit down for three
hours a day if I was just subdued
and lived in a castle somewhere.
But I need to converse with this man,
bring him to me.
The only way you can really have a,
a car,
it has to be worthwhile for them to so
they can get their message out. So it's,
this whole thing has been a
real symbiotic exchange. So, uh,
when you guys, I can't say it enough,
people keep telling me, you know, hey,
this podcast changed.
You're changed my life. I,
I've heard it before and I appreciate
the fuck out of it every time.
And there's no other way to
say it, you know. Um, we're,
we're blown away by this whole thing.
We appreciate it.
Is this like love music in the background?
I've had the time of my life. Uh,
Sam is that dirty dancing?
Yes. Oh, was beautiful.
But there was two hours put baby in a
corner. Okay. All right. So Joe rogan.net.
Go get it. It's available on paypal
and a, I think Amazon and um,
hopefully Amazon's already by today.
It was supposed to be. If it's not,
it should be around tomorrow,
but um, that's it. All right.
Go Fuck yourself or not. I don't
care honey. Honey, honey. Honey,
would you like play another song?
Honey?
Honey would be joining us this
Friday at the end of the world show.
The first time we'd ever done a show with
band ever in the history of the world.
Yeah, no pressure. Nothing. We've
never yet, please be awesome.
You guys I believe are the first
people that played live in here, right?
Warranty. Yeah. Yeah. Everlast was
second. You guys were first. Yeah,
we came for Everlast. Sherry's
left and right too. Yeah. Yeah.
We Love Pop and Cherries.
Hello?
I think you just contributed to
rape culture again. No, no, no.
They can be consensual and Cherry and uh,
she's my cherry pie.
Hey, thanks for having
us on here again, please.
We love you guys and the people that,
uh,
that's online love you guys.
The people that we, we,
we've talked to so many people that say
thank you for turning us on the honey
honey, Twitter and they're awesome.
Isn't that cool? It's so great.
It's so good. I don't
know what happened, man,
but we have the coolest fucking people
in the world that are connected to us.
I really don't get it. I don't,
I don't know how it took place.
It's an amazing lack of
douchebags staggering the
actual douche numbers to cool
people numbers. It's crazy. It doesn't
exist anywhere else on the earth.
We're creating utopia. It's pretty
cool and we appreciate it. Listen, we,
we appreciate you guys.
You guys are awesome.
You're incredibly talented
and like I said before,
we do whatever the fuck we
can to promote you guys.
Thank you. Well, speaking of, I want to
say that we have a show in Cleveland,
my hometown on a 1220 sixth that's the
day after Christmas at the House of Blues
in downtown and I feel like it's like
only half full right now off of Cleveland
in the, in the area were headlining.
So we're going to play for a nice,
nice chunk of time. When you guys do a
headline said, how long do you play for?
I think they're going to
do 70 minutes. Yeah, 70 75
that's a good number.
I'd like to do that on standup too.
When I do more than that, I feel
like I'm testing people's pain there.
Their attention. They're like enough,
dude. How much more you want to attention?
Well, we talk a lot too. You know,
there's a lot of, this is just, you know,
do you guys have like Paul
Stanley type banter? Yeah.
Like, like Paul Stanley from kiss.
Oh. I was like, is that a committee?
I thought it was that guy.
There was like,
oh no, we never see that. Brian
pull, pull some of that up.
Paul Stanley introducing for
kiss before we play this song.
Paul Shaffer.
No.
Paul Stanley from Kiss Paul
Stanley talks to the audience.
It's great. No, you have to do it.
You have to be totally fucking cheesy.
Yeah. Paul tally talks to the audience.
This is a short video of Paul Stanley
talking and playing with the audience at a
kiss alive. 35 concert. That's a
we should do, but that's
just, that's Peter. Chris,
Paul Stanley does.
They've made cds out of it and the dude,
whoever you are that's made those cds.
I forget your name. Thank you very much.
Guy sent me a stack of them.
They're hilarious.
It's all Paul's down
from in between songs.
Shit.
It's like super duty brute. He's getting
mad and shit with a laser. He's getting,
oh, some guys get a laser
laser come here. Schmuck.
Come here, schmuck. No, you know? Yeah.
People know you're an old Jew when you're,
you're calling a guy schmuck
and you don't have a shirt on.
Try to find that one. He
talks to the audience. Yeah,
that's just so they could
get rid of some douchebag.
Is that it was amazing. Yeah. How
about that one? What was that one? Oh,
that's another one. It's
all making fun. Anyway,
my point is I have no point.
That's my point.
My point is he's a hell of a show
him in that Paul Stanley got it.
Smart guys. Those kisses. They
made a lot of money though.
You guys fans. What kind of music did
you listen to growing up? I listened to,
I have a really,
really old dad,
so I was listening to like
classical music and music.
Low Twenties and thirties and how old's
your dad? He's super old. He's 91 now.
Oh wait, how old are
you? I'm 27 Oh shit. You,
and this was before Cialis.
Five hours
bars for how old was your jars?
28 years younger than him.
God bless your dad.
Served in World War II in the Pacific
and in stormed the airfields of Pelu.
Oh Shit. Yeah, he's hard.
He's amazingly shit. Marc Jaffe, dude.
Do your dad is a hero.
It's,
that's why he got a boner is 28
years younger. Check. Yeah. A hero.
Hero boner.
You don't look Asian.
How dare you?
He's Russian.
He's a mail order bride.
Easy, easy. Talking about
mom and dad here in the Fox.
So you listened to classic shit. It's
like, yeah, well I'll listen to like,
he would start,
you know there's an opera
called the magic flute. Yup. That's gone
there. This is Mozart, Mozart opera,
couple of magic flute.
He played every single weekend.
So we'd just be blasting heat blasted,
like he was playing ACDC. But yeah.
Really? Wow. Every, every weekend. Yeah.
Can't remember that.
And then, um, what did he get you
into playing music? No, not really.
Neither of them did.
They didn't really play that much,
but I don't know where it started,
but I just decided I want
to play violin first.
And I played violin when I
was like six and I dropped it.
And then I started playing drums and
from there on it just kind of freaked out
about it and go. So from
age six, you started with
violin? Yeah. Wow. I can't play it
at all anymore. No. It's a shame.
I feel like actually it would come back
if I really put it in the time to give
it a whirl. Yeah. I think no,
I'm not serious. I believe in you. I
think you can do it too. Mike am my chip
came out of rocky. There
is no tomorrow. Um,
what about you Suzanne?
How'd you start?
Um,
well I listened to a lot of like
juxtapose with my folks a ran an Italian
restaurant,
so I grew up with a lot of like jazz,
like Rosemary Clooney and Frank Sinatra
and we pre month, stuff like that. Um,
and I like that a lot.
And then like regular,
like nineties rock pop,
like Scorpions. My mom, no,
my mom was to rock set. There was a lot
of rock set in the car. What's rocks at?
Um, oh God. Um, w what's their
song? Hold on. It'll come to me.
Fucking a red bands. Where
we at here there was, oh God,
we're upset. It'll come. Hold on.
But there's, there's rock set. Yeah.
Well how does it go? Uh, you're
trapped. The villa. Yeah.
Is there anything in fucking medicine
in it? None of it was that song. Yes.
So there's that. Like my, my mom was
the more sort of contemporary culture.
My Dad and I used to listen to a lot of
journey together and harmonize you guys
just to harmonize together.
I remember actually stop.
It was crazy and I'd be like, you
take the hi. And he'd be like, no,
dad would sing journey together. And My
dad played some, some acoustic guitar. Oh,
you know, he, he really like
Jethro Tull a lot. And Hailey.
Yeah, he was, you know, he,
he had a band in the 70s
and mustache and a perm.
Whoa. Your Dad's pretty, pretty hip.
That guy. Did he have bell bottoms?
I hope not, but yeah, of course.
No, I'm sure he did. Yeah.
There's all these pictures of my,
My,
my dad and my grandfather
and my uncles and they,
they look like Italian mobsters.
Like they just, everybody has like,
everything's like together. There's
like tailored suits and like glass,
big glasses and that's just the 70s now
retiring Elton John Glasses. Totally.
It was totally gay. Yeah. But um,
time the 70s or so, it's like they got
disconnected from the mother
nipple of drugs. You know,
it's like in the 60s they all had an
acid and marijuana and mushrooms and then
the 70s like, oh, what are we
going to do? Stay sober man,
lose pills, pills, confused.
Motherfuckers started wearing pointy
shoes and bell bottoms, big belt buckles.
What am I doing? I don't
what happened back then.
Dudes for the most part had such,
there was such a wardrobe wise speaking,
they were so much more of an effort put
into what guys would wear on a regular
basis because they didn't have match.com
couldn't just find people online.
You get to pretend to be
something you weren't,
you had to go somewhere and wear the
outfit and do whatever you could get
someone to touch you. Jesus
Christ. What do I have to like,
do I have to dance? You know, men
are essentially junkies and they're,
they're born into this world junkies and
then they go out as young men with full
raging hormones and it's this massive
quest to figure out how to get someone to
touch you. And what do I have to do? How,
what do I have to pretend I
have to talk a certain way,
cut my hair a certain way.
Let me just get that figured out first.
And every man is struggling with that
from the time where young, when we're 16,
17, 18 the conversations we have
is all about how we figure it out.
How to fucking get them to like us.
Yeah.
Well that's what breeding is all about.
If it wasn't for that sense of urgency,
there'd be three people on the
planet, you know, you'd have to,
the only reason why we do it is because
we are junkies. We're just so crazy.
Just get rid of the loads. Just get him
in there. Quite so many touch. Right?
And so there you go with bell bottoms,
fucking confusing wardrobe things.
It takes like 10 years for people to
go. What the fuck are we doing? Yeah.
What the fuck are we doing? These things
looks too, but it's fun. You're right man.
Fuck Bell Bottoms, pants are
still here. Okay. Pants work.
Everybody's cool with genes. Genes have
been around since fucking, you know,
butch Cassidy and the Sundance kid at
the same jeans that you wear there wear
jeans. They were canvas,
which is interesting.
Most clothes and pants
during like the minor days,
the cowboy days were actually made with
cannabis. They were made out of hemp.
Yeah. Most clothes. Yeah.
Well before the, um, the, the,
before slavery was illegal,
that's what most shit was made with the,
they made more close with,
uh,
with hemp and more flags and sales.
All that stuff is made with hemp because
it's much, much stronger than cotton.
And then when Eli Whitney came
along and made the cotton gin, oh,
then it became really easy
to make shit with cotton.
And then the decorticator
was invented in the 1930s.
In the 1930s was right after
prohibition for alcohol had ended.
And they were trying to figure out
what to do with all these fucking drug
enforcement agents that were
assigned to go after alcohol.
And one of the things they did was a
concerted effort between this Guy William
Randolph Hearst that
owned all the newspapers.
We also owned all these paper mills and
the cover of Popular Science magazine
had this article hemp,
the new billion dollar crop.
And so everybody was switching over
to hemp cause they had created this
decorticator which allows you to
effectively processed to hemp fiber,
the stalk of the plant,
which is like credibly useful
for making paper and close it.
It allowed you to process
it without slavery,
allows you to process it like
an economically effectively.
And so William Randolph Hearst started
printing all these articles about
marijuana and about how marijuana was
causing blacks and Mexicans to rape white
women. So that's how they
shut down the hemp business.
It was all about hemp as a commodity.
It wasn't about cotton interests his own.
He was protecting paper because he
owned paper mills. He was a, um, uh,
also dupont had an interest in it
because dupont came up with the chemical
composition for nylon to make ropes.
And previously all ropes had been
made at a hemp. So there was, uh,
it's, it's, it's, it's readily
available. You can get it online.
It's amazing. That is very impressive.
It's just memory. That's all it is.
It's just, look, you asked me
shit about important things,
like where are your taxes go?
I don't really know that.
We don't want to know. You should know
or be our overlords are lying to us,
but that's the only reason why it's still
legal today or it's still legal today
is now it's gone from a
textile and uh, you know, in a,
in an issue with like nylon,
now it's gone to pharmaceutical drugs and
the influence of pharmaceutical drugs.
The only reason why it's,
and then there's also people that
would profit from it being illegal.
Like prison guard unions actively
spend money to try to keep marijuana,
illegal private prisons.
They will actively try to
spend money to keep marijuana.
And we didn't go because they want to
keep the prison stock cause that's what
they make money. Not Amazing.
Yeah. Private prison unions,
prison guard unions spend money to make
sure that drug stay illegal. That's cute.
Isn't that cute?
Because they make money.
I mean it literally is like slavery.
I mean if it wasn't illegal,
those people wouldn't be in jail.
They'd be free.
So you make something that they do and
you spend money to keep it illegal.
Something enjoy it.
It doesn't hurt anybody else.
You spend money to keep it illegal so
you can enslave them and make money from
the fact that they're locked in a
cage that you own mass incarceration.
That's amazing. Gary. We're going
to look back on this day in,
in the future when people are,
when they have full access to
everything including thoughts and all,
all misinformation will be
accounted for and corrected.
We will look back with great shame
and how stupid we ran this world.
We will look back at it with
great shame at the people that we
called our leaders and what a
group of fucking monkeys they are.
When you see them arguing about the
fiscal cliff and all this other nonsense,
you realized these are incredibly flawed
human beings from a different time and
an error and they're all trying to appease
these fucking monsters that put them
into position. These,
these, these corporations,
they spend millions of dollars in
associate pathic way to try to profit from
these fucks representing them.
We're going to look back on this
and we're going to be really,
really shocked that we were this week.
We're going to be really shocked that
it was this pathetic with our incredible
access to information that we were
still this wonky with our system of
government and our system,
money and welfare and and, and,
and protecting each other and our sense
of community in our willingness to go
into wars. We're going to look back
on it. It's going to be shocking.
Just as shocking as the inquisition.
Don't know what they're doing.
You know? I think that it's,
it is,
it is a joke to see how,
how the world is run or a country or
whatever. Sometimes. Not all the time,
but you know, I don't think that it,
it's, it goes like under their radar.
I think it's just like
politics and selfishness.
It's damp and it's also completely
out of control. It's so big.
Like the system is so interconnected.
There's hundreds of
different organizations.
There's more than a hundred
different countries.
There's all this fucking politics.
There's a certain amount
of natural resources that
they need every fucking day.
There's so much is going on.
There's so many different connected
issues and does so many fucking human
beings. It's so hard. It's like
people were born into this system.
It's completely chaotic. It's completely
out of control, completely corrupt.
And it's like everybody agrees. Everybody
looks at it and says it's a mass,
but no one knows what to do. And they
try to work within the system to fix it,
but that doesn't seem to be working.
So it's like our options are wait for
it to completely fall apart and come up
with something totally new or slowly sort
of chip away at this horrible problem
that our ancestors have created and left
us with because that's the real issue.
It's like you and I and we, we
never, we didn't create this world.
We didn't decide to invade Afghanistan
and we say we are going to war with Iraq.
We have nothing to do with that.
The fact that some human
beings that somehow or another
represent us cause we're
all in this one patch of dirt together,
his car Raese and it's always been crazy.
It was crazy when the Romans did it.
It's crazy when the Greeks did it,
but it's even more crazy when we do it.
It's more crazy when we
do it because we have,
we have the access to the information
that allows us to see the wiring under the
board and see what's really motivating
this whole thing and see where this is
all going from. And it's
embarrassing. It's embarrassing.
It's embarrassing with there
were so dumb that this is,
these are our leaders at guys like Newt
Gingrich really think there could be
president. It's embarrassing.
It's embarrassing. Oh,
of it that a guy like Mitt Romney can
have this incredibly horrific record in
business and still put himself up as a
businessman for the people and almost get
elected,
but just as crazy,
the guy like Obama can win the Nobel
Peace Prize then send 30,000 more people
with guns to Afghanistan.
Fucking crazy. We're crazy shit.
Yeah. Circumstances.
Circumstances are right.
It's, it's such a, it's just
like an endless, it's like
that not, what's that thing?
That Gordian knot or whatever
we just talking about it.
There's that story about Alexander
the Great and he has this,
not that no one can untie.
It's just this endlessly complex knot
and you can't cut it actually that,
that's what he did. He just sliced it
in half and destroyed this Gordian knot.
I've never heard of that Gordian knot.
Yeah. Um, and you have these
people, I don't know. It's, wow.
It's the first time I've ever heard that.
Um,
you're dealing with this
infinitely complex situation
and you still have humans
that are trying to solve
it. Yeah. So I dunno.
I think sometimes
there's sometimes there's a lot
of energy put towards, you know,
defaming the people in
power and sing and I'm not,
I'm not a supporter of a lot of the
people that you're talking about are the
systems that govern, but I think it
was interesting like this last week,
sorry to get back on this,
but the shooting thing and there's this
knee jerk reaction that comes from a
place of anger with a lot of people and
I think that ends up just being wasted
energy. And when people just
start spouting off about
how you know, things are,
are, aren't the way they
should be and reacting angrily,
it takes away energy from
changing individual lifestyles,
which is the only thing we
can really do. Right? Like,
that's the only thing that you can
change is how you're living your life and
your usage of these resources that are
basically the reason why we're in all
these difficult situations because
of the way we live. Our lives,
takes up x amount of resource
from, you know, Afghan Joe.
So we have to go in there and take
his stuff and create, you know,
complicated situations we can't get
out of. Right. You know, I dunno, I'm,
I'm just rambling here.
No, no, no. I agree with you in,
in a lot of ways and I think that,
um, I would hate to have to be,
I think if you were elected
president right now, you'd be fucked.
I think anybody would be people,
even with good intentions,
I think there's so many things you have
to deal with. There's so many pressures,
so, so much going on and you know, as much
as you want to be the voice of reason,
you live in a fucking crazy world.
The Pakistan still exists. Okay.
So fucking completely disconnected
country with nuclear arms and a hate for
India, their next door neighbor
and they're there. I mean,
we had Shane Smith from vice.com and
he's talking about how, you know,
leaders from that part of the
world have said they want to strap
themselves with nuclear bombs and
clover and destroy their enemies,
but they're fucking crazy.
And this is 2012 and this is a reality
that people have to deal with. You know,
that's why you need navy seals. You need
the army, you need the marines, you need,
I mean, it sounds, people want it. They
don't want to think that that's real.
They don't want to think that you,
you do need a military.
You fucking need a military man
unless you want your, your, your,
your wife raped in the
street by Chinese soldiers.
And I'm not saying the
Chinese want to do that,
but I'm saying that that traditionally
has been what human beings have done.
That's what Gangas Kahn did. That's
what the Romans did, is the Greeks did.
People have been taking over
people from the history, from the,
for the first time people
started writing things down.
It's a fucking series of stories
about people taking over other people.
That's what everybody's always done
and if you don't protect the people,
then that's most likely going to happen
because we really haven't evolved enough
to not to not have it happen.
You know,
it would be beautiful if everybody
was all peace, love and Kumbaya,
but the reality is if you actually
pay attention to the news,
there's a lot of non Kumbaya type shit
going down all over the world. You know,
you,
you need a little bit of a military.
The problem is you've got a military
and then you have a bunch of people that
decide,
you know,
fucking son his bitches over here and
then we've got some oil and make a lot of
money.
Then you go 2012 I have no point to this
and the this bitch and doesn't do any
good. And the only, the only,
the only thing you could
possibly have was it somebody,
maybe you could listen to me and run
for president and make some sense.
That's it. The young, the young people,
the only people that you can change.
You're not going to change Newt Gingrich,
that all Kofi fuck,
he's not going to take mushrooms. Well,
you gotta do to Newt Gingrich. Hey,
going to change new kangaroos.
Yes, yes, yes. I slept with him.
It freak out and have a heart attack,
cut his dick off and drown himself
in a bathtub. You go crazy.
No way to ah, no, that's no way to go.
This isn't mean, there's no point to this.
I mean,
we've,
we've had this conversation with a hundred
different people a hundred different
times and there's no,
I don't think that,
um,
I really get so uncomfortable talking
about these things because I don't feel
like I'm, I've informed myself
enough to have a strong opinion. Um,
but my instincts and just,
I agree with you that it doesn't matter
who's president. It's like you're,
you're fucked because you've inherited
is a mountain of Shit, you know?
Um,
for centuries I think that unfortunately,
and I'm,
I got forbid, but you know, I
don't, I don't think that, um,
you know,
I think it's going to be something
huge that's going to change everything.
And I don't know what that is. I don't
know if that's something catastrophic.
I don't know if that's the aliens
coming or whatever the fuck I,
but something else would have to
happen for anything to really change.
I think it's happening right in front
of our face. I think it's the Internet.
Oh yeah.
If there's an alien. I think the aliens,
the Internet, the, the, the, this,
this alien entity that is created
by humans that allows to connect
and exponentially grow together in some
strange way that would never be possible
without it to have access to information
that will never be available and no one
saw coming.
No one saw it coming and it's a factor.
It's an alien factor created by human
beings. It's alien to the earth.
It's alien to any of the systems that
have been set up before as far as natural
systems of natural selection, of,
of, of survival, of the fittest.
Any of those select.
This is an alien system.
This is an access to information
in language. If the, if
something happens with,
what'd you say bro?
If the,
like none of us have the
know how most people,
like if if the Wifi gets knocked out,
you know what I mean?
Like you lose all access to
no, that's true. I mean we look,
but you know what? If you're,
you're a juggler had slit, your blood
falls out and you're done. You know
God, I hope the Internet. That's why I'm
saying I need to think it's cultural.
It's culturally my bows and
arrows analogous to our blood.
Which ones are the good
berries in the bad berries?
You know that ultimate fighter star
with the that that broke his penis? Yes.
Oh God, yes. Totally
magical ray lb.
Apparently he had a girl hopping
up and down on his Johnson and she
miscalculated her exit and reentry and
it was tank to tip snapped his Penai
in the hospital for several days getting
his shaft repaired and who knows if
I've ever totally recover.
That's how,
that's how I won.
Ultimate fighter fucks that
tendon dick tissue optic tissue.
Yeah, it's officially
dictation. I've never broken it,
but I heard it a couple of times.
Got It.
You can't be,
you can't let a strange girl doesn't
know how long you penises ride you. Okay?
You got to,
you should hold firmly onto her waist
and control her exit and reentry.
You gotta be careful.
You got to have a good grip on the waist
and you got to do a lot of kettlebells
tow. You want to be able to pick
her up in case she gets crazy.
You want to be able to
troll that thrust. It's very
important, you know? I mean,
a lot of girls would like to be on top.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Folks don't get wrong, but you
men to protect your penis. Okay?
And the way to protect your penis has
a firm grip on the hips as gotta be a
certain point where you're in danger.
When they passed this,
you know how long you,
Dick is.
Okay? Don't get like bouncing up and down.
That's the only way to break a dick.
If he missed fired that fucking that
is you would know you were doing,
then you would stop while you're doing
it. You wouldn't do it. It's still in.
The only way to break a
dick is a girl to be on top.
I think that's 100% of all the
broken decks I've come from.
A girl being outside is a few off the
bed falls and stuff like that. Yeah.
Those guys are those natural selection.
They're supposed to fall,
landed on his dick.
It's happened and then you broke it.
That deck that's happened.
Dude's tripped and landed on his dick
and Jujitsu once.
I used to not wear a cup and my God,
that story again. You
love the store. I go,
I got kneed in the Dick like on the
deck, like flat and my deck out. Bam.
Really hard by my friend
Einstein, incidentally. Funny
nickname. It's great guy.
Anyway, it was, it wasn't his fault,
it was just trying to pass my guard.
He and he slammed his need and my dick
and I didn't know I was hurt. I mean,
I knew it hurt, but I thought it was okay.
And, uh, you know, it's just like, ah,
and then you know,
you,
you sit down for a minute or so
and then he'd go back in when,
when not in so much pain.
But then when I went to the
locker room after training, uh,
I had blue shorts on and I,
or blue pants on.
I didn't know I took my pants off
of my jock strip was red with blood.
Oh my gosh.
So my deck had been bleeding into my jock
strap and then I peed and it came out
of my Dick. It was bloody. So
then I have to figure out, okay,
do I overreact here or do I treat
it like I would treat my nose?
Because if my nose,
my nose is important to me,
my nose is bloody,
I would go to a doctor.
So this is one of the things you have
to do when you do Jujitsu on a regular
basis, you're always
getting hurt. It's all,
you've got to know what the difference
between a torn ACL is and you know, a,
a cramp muscle, you know,
so I had to figure out,
so what I did was I decided I was going to
masturbate. So went home. No, you, yeah,
no, no. I went home and I was
like, if I have a hard on,
I'm sure my dick still
works and so I'm good.
So I got a hard on and a Jack
[inaudible] and it looked like an embryo.
It looked like, like the
inside of an egg. No,
no, I don't have much as a
line. This is not online anyway,
but,
and it came out that way when a PD came
out of the way for three or four days
and it slowly, like less
and less. So I was like,
I kept touching it and make sure
it's not effectives no pain.
I checked my temperature, no fever, and
everything's cool. There's no infection,
so it's all right. Just took
a few days off. That was it.
It healed up pretty sure it's okay.
And I made a baby since then,
so it's all good.
I think I made both of
my babies since then,
so it's 100% fires,
but it was a little scary,
but it didn't look scary.
It looked normal on the outside.
That's why I was so confident. It
wasn't like funny, swollen, felt better,
didn't hurt. That was a crazy thing.
It just blood was coming out of it.
That is bizarre.
Bizarre when you get need that big,
oh that is from my dick
didn't put it online. That's just blood.
But it was really weird. But it was,
it was also, I was like really
questioning my own judgment. I was like,
what did I just really just
jerk off after I broke my Dick?
A fuck is wrong with me.
And I was like sitting there looking
at the sink looking at this, you know?
And I did it like in
a medical sort of way.
I didn't like sit in front of like
a computer. Like Ah, Yay, fuck.
He really had a stern look on your,
I was like all medical shit.
I'm sure I probably thought about like
some ex girlfriend or something to get
the job done.
But it was,
you know, a clinical approach and
everything. I wanted to make sure
that my dick worked.
Did that disturb you and Nina Hartley
was talking about wearing gloves when she
was on [inaudible].
Kevin rather have a person where
it glove and put his finger in her.
We have Nina Hartley on.
Do you know who she is?
Still old school porn star from like the
eighties and she's still doing orgies
and banging
people all over the world.
I do know who that is.
She likes to,
when people work gloves,
she wears gloves and she wants
them to wear gloves. Like mittens.
Yeah, like big Christmas Santa Claus
type gloves. She wants them to be clean.
She wants everybody to be clean.
I don't blame her. I mean,
I mean come on, you don't
think you're going in there.
Action photography thing.
How dare you show my ass.
How can we can show my ass on Ustream?
But you can't show that the hookers
tip because that's not your real,
but you told me
it's not my real bud.
You know what? You guys were
gonna play another song about it.
I kind of like where this is.
Go play one.
It's called Dick Tissue Tissue.
You guys have a song called
Dick Shit. Tissue reset. No,
no, no. I just don't know if I want
to play this song. What song is this?
It's a new song. It's a
tender one. Can we talk about,
can we like bring it down?
Bring it down. I kept,
my kids are awesome.
They're awesome. Yeah, I
love them. They're fun.
Great little girls, little tiny
girls that I hang out with every day.
A big part of my day is hanging
out. I'm like, you like, yes.
Do your children like no question.
But uh, it's not just my children.
It's also a little four year
old individual who happens
to be a girl and she's
experiencing all these girl things
and I want to be like, what the fuck?
We're not going to go see that.
I don't want to get to see that shit,
but for whatever it is
that she wants to go to,
like we have to go see the Grinch
like you have to like do it,
will like get excited with her.
Like do you want to go to the carousel?
Oh yes. I'll be so good.
I want to ride a unicorn.
Do you think the Unicorn will be
available? Like I bet it will available.
Oh yeah. She's wicked smart. She's
crazy smart, but it's like you,
you get to see things through
the eyes of a four year old girl.
It's really interesting. It's
fascinating. It's incredibly fascinating.
I mean obviously I love her to death.
She's amazing and I'm so
happy just to having children.
It's like a really incredible
experience.
It's really hard to wrap your head
around it and I don't recommend it to
everybody and I don't recommend it to
people who are in bad situations in their
relationship or stressed out,
but,
but if you got your ducks in order and
you're in a good place with a nice person,
having a kid is a crazy
experience when you're, you know,
when you could just see
it's going to be hard times.
But when you get to hang out with this
little person that you literally love
more than you love your own life,
like you would sacrifice your own
life in order to keep them happy.
It's a very strange thing.
It's like as an entertainer,
I'm sure you guys can relate to this,
especially being around a lot of other
entertainers, you guys are very balanced,
but not a lot of us are. You
know, a lot of us are very
me, me, me, me, me, you know,
and it's really hard to get past that.
There's a lot of selfish ideas out there
in the world of art and creativity.
And one of the things that's been little
really freeing to me is to actually
have someone in my life, you
know, have people in my life,
not just one gang.
These little people that I literally
love more than I liked me. You know,
I want more for them than
for me. And that's, I always
thought that was bullshit.
I always thought that was what people said
because they wanted to hear people go,
aw, he's so sensitive. Oh he's so yoga.
You know what I mean? It sounds
like horse shit. But then when you,
you understand the actual relationship
between a parent and a child,
it's not just a little human being.
It's a little human being that is a part
of you. I mean they, they, they literally,
if it's not, you could never
understand it unless it's yours. The,
that biological switches that go
off of very strange, you know, like,
so your whole,
your whole feeling about love in general
changes when you have children and my
whole outlook on human beings
because once I had children,
I changed the way I looked at everybody.
I didn't,
I don't look at adults as adults anymore.
I look at adults as
babies that became adults.
I look at adults as like these bundles
of potential that slowly but surely
became a grown up human being. What
are you playing to Brian? No baby.
You play in babies eating and lemons.
Have you given your babies the lemons yet?
Yeah, they're like lemmings.
They eat them. It's weird.
Yeah. They make that face.
Then they bite down chew.
There's a whole community of
baby's eating lemon grass.
It's okay because it's not painful,
but it is kinda crazy. You know,
like you don't feel like the kids
getting tortured because look,
they still ate it. They don't wipe
their mouth or they just go, Whoa,
that was a lie.
A kid's a pussy.
I kid freaked out from a wine lambs.
Aren't even that bad. You little fuck.
When I was a kid we had to walk 20
miles in the snow just to get a line.
You feel like we are, we're in the
right groove now. We might gotten there.
All right.
What's this next song? Well, it's uh,
it's, it's kind of called,
it's got a weird name.
I'm not sure if this is what we're
going to call it, but the, the courses,
which are you going to do now? And it's
not like water, like spelling it out,
you know? So like what, this is
not even named yet. Not really. No.
So to have a chance to hear a
silence, not even name, maybe,
maybe you can name it Joe,
and that'll, that'll be,
maybe we'll ask the people on Twitter,
people on your stream, maybe not.
Maybe not. Maybe not. We're not.
We're not guaranteeing shit.
But then you come up with the perfect name
and Bennett, Suzanne Angle. Holy Shit.
That guy.
Fuck stick 69 cold blooded.
He found it.
He found the right navy balls of steel
can help us out here. Balls of steel.
Where are you?
You introduced us.
He's still on my, we are all balls. Deal
bloody balls. Bloody balls of steel.
Shout out to Duncan
Trussell. Oh, oh, oh. Oh.
Hardest deal is the ball of steel.
Tom Paine and Lance Armstrong could
form a true it trio tears. Oh my God.
What's it called? Trio. It's true. Yeah.
I want to see a tree yet. I'm gonna
Quartet sounds better than trio. Trio.
Trio. Sounds like you got out next
time we come in, get to take one more.
So all the way the working title. Um,
yeah. Uh, what are you going to do now?
Which going to do now ladies
and gentlemen on Twitter,
now's your time to be heard.
Ben and Suzanne are listening. Yeah. And
judging you. Just kidding. We're not,
except you.
Okay.
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.
Ooh,
mmm.
Wait,
you,
ah,
Yay.
Yes.
Know
the gay
you,
everyone.
Hi.
You can't change him.
Okay.
Ooh, wait, no, the dog came.
Yeah.
Whoa,
whoa.
Yes.
Awesome.
I really liked that one.
That was great. Cool. Wow.
That's bad ass. Play another one.
One more. Um, oh shit. Come on. You fucks.
You guys are professionals but area. Oh
well, uh, I keep playing fiddle right now.
What are you gonna play? What is it?
God of love. That's kind of bummer one.
It's so great song that Ben
wrote and I think it's awesome.
Why you think it's a bummer?
Because of the lyrics and how it sounds,
but what else?
What?
What else can we something bad
ass that we should call it that.
I want to hear the God that's
us putting it out there.
We've never played it live before. It's
to do it like it's brand spanking new.
Listen, we love you. Do it. Make it
happen. I don't care. We can shine.
Okay. I hope you guys just accept
us out there. Okay. Shit. Huh?
Here we go.
Oh God.
Of Love.
If there is one,
you got me pin.
So a tab
and I slapped the phone.
Whoa.
At chata tag out.
God,
no team makes me sad.
I know now I'm the jealous
and I don't need to prove it. Julia. Yeah,
I can be an angry Mama.
Ooh.
You know my hands and knees.
Ooh,
sorry.
Why
don't you tell him?
Oh God of love.
Make me a fun friends.
Oh
my end. Since giving me, hey
give me skin. The taste.
Even my hips just throw.
Oh and then I'll give him
praise your name.
Yeah,
I'll pay your tab even though crazy.
Ooh It on my hands and knees.
Tell me
g
turn and love is
oh even school
good.
I ever asked for more as well.
What I've been waiting for
because I feel confused.
Feel like a train wreck
and all the flowers that,
yeah,
now I'm a quiet,
I'm a sound soul so it won't you
to heal me Stan and pain motto.
Ooh.
You know my hands and knees.
She tell me.
That wasn't a bummer at all. That
was awesome. Yeah that was awesome.
How about the ballot of Buck Angel?
So glad you said that. Cause I was really
hoping on Dick Bloody frosty trucks
on Twitter suggested that
the ballot of buck angel,
do they really fuck. Yeah Dude, I want
to, I want to hang out with that guy.
Fuck Yeah Dude. With that guy or buck
angel. Which one? If you had to, Oh,
I've already hung out with buck angel.
Let me come on. Look at this. Oh,
he's such a kind man tender. Yeah,
very, very tender and really like very,
very shoplifts.
Genuinely
talking about actually
absolutely ones that sof
Barb. Yeah, it's dried. His proud
you've done is laptop's dead.
Oh my God. Yeah. I don't mind
trainees but not that kind of,
that's a little strong
going the other way.
Yes. There's, there's different ways
to slice it. No Pun intended. Oh,
you're okay with the other group?
Uh, more compatible with the
men who want to be women.
Then with the women who want to be men.
Those confused me. More, more compatible
PC way. We'll have you looked at
it like what would you as a man,
what would you choose? We have to wrap
this up soon. What would you choose?
Would you rather be the the man who dates
the man who used to be a woman but is
now a man or you know what I mean?
Like fucking,
I should ask Ben,
would you rather be a date?
Would you rather date of bucking Joe
who's clearly very manly but has a vagina
or like a little tie,
little Thai boy,
a twinkie type situation.
That'd be careful
who becomes a woman.
You would rather have that right?
Who would rather have a man who
like at least looks like a woman?
You're saying like a manly vagina
having Ryan or a buck angels.
Truly a man. Truly a man, but not
really, really is a woman has a vagina.
Would you rather have that or would you
rather have a guy who used to be a guy
but wanting to be a girl? Always felt
he was a girl but really looks like
girl when I talked to them.
Are they going to listen to you and
what are we going to talk about that?
Don't you have friends? What's going
on? Surely want out of a relationship.
You want them to listen to you.
They get a dog man talks,
I listened to you and they don't have
to fund. Got Larry Bird and Larry Bird.
Maybe Larry Berg will talk to you.
You won't need a relationship anymore.
Just jerk off Larry Bird and your life
and cut all the complications out man
between twinks a short transsexual,
right?
No twinks or a little gay
fellows who a are, you know,
fairly non muscular and very boy like
and what did they call him and China.
Oh.
Oh your son of a bitch.
He and he fucking prepared that one.
He prepared that one in his
shitty little mine for like
20 seconds for like an hour.
He was rolling a while
introduced that one
bitch by batch.
Controversial Thursday night red band
will be at the Improv in Hollywood the
night before the end of the world show.
Joey d is going to be there.
I'm most likely going to be there.
Let's just say I'm going to be there.
Fuck I can do that. Um, yeah. Like I said,
there's only 60 tickets
left for [inaudible] for the
Wiltern with honey honey.
He wants to come. She can come to. If
you guys want to. Ben, come to you. Fuck.
I said she can come. Oh, cheap
honey honey. I don't
care. He will do that.
He has no fewer pills. He has no
fear of making out with them. Paul,
he has sex with you. Trust me. I'm
under the influence for three days.
So the kids Randy and ready,
ladies and gentlemen,
if you're in the Pasadena
area, Brown, red,
bright red ban to the main stage though.
You got some crappy loads.
Were you $14 Margarita step on up.
Ruined it.
Yes.
You son
of a bitch. Settle the fuck down. Okay.
Uh,
this show essentially is over.
This is a fun one. It got
dark, but it was, that was good
being on it. You know, if,
uh, if it wasn't for you guys,
we probably would've never went down.
The road of musical guests
has been really fun.
Balls of steel, whatever it was, was it,
he was in the fucking stars for us guys.
Yeah,
I think it was.
It was a, I mean the guy,
if you don't know the story,
a guy am I messed up or sent me a message,
a personal message,
said this is going to
be a new favorite band.
And it was you guys playing angel of death
on the top of a roof somewhere and in
la. And it was an acoustic version
of it. And I was like, wow,
these guys are fucking good.
And then I just started,
I think I saw my little toy gun.
I think that was the next song I saw.
And I just watched a bunch of your
videos and I'm like, Holy Shit,
these guys are awesome.
And somehow or another we all got
together and now we're besties.
It's pretty awesome. We are. I like what's
happening here guys. It's beautiful.
You know,
this is one of the coolest things about
the internet is the ability to connect
people. The other cool thing,
stalkers, that's not, oh,
that's cool.
I'm being facetious. That's the problem
with the ability to connect people.
Some people are just not fully developed.
They're not ready.
Can I know for others,
not,
not to segue from stockers at all because
that was like a wrong place to go from.
But I do want to have a little shout
out and a thank you to all the amazing
death squad fans that
have come to our shows.
There's some incredible people
that we've met on our, on our,
it'd be thanking a death squad during our
travels and think about how weird that
is.
I'd like to thank the desk.
Why can't you ever think those words would
come here? I don't think I would know.
Well, they never thought we would
call ourselves a desk quad either.
So why do you call them the death squad?
We're on the opiate Anthony show. What
was it, 2006 or some shit like that. Yeah.
And uh, oop, when we walked in,
I walked in with Tate Fletcher's big
giant dude from the ultimate fighter,
good buddy of ours.
And uh,
Eddie Bravo who's a black belt in
Brazilian Jujitsu and Opie goes, oh,
here's Joe Rogan. He brought
in the death squad. Like,
like there's these people that were
killers and we just as a joke start a
calling ourselves a desk squad,
you know, because he said that.
And then Brian started desk squad
podcast network and it's sort of spread
through that.
And then Brian started selling the desk
squad tee shirts and then people showed
up at shows and they're all wearing these
desk squad tee shirts and now people
like put Hashtag [inaudible] Hashtag
[inaudible] the yeah, it's crazy.
And Brian does like desk squad shows,
he calls it the comedy
shows desk watch shows.
It just was a crazy thing that
sorta just grew and became weird
like our group of friends.
But yeah, it's like our gang,
you know like we're approving like if,
if you're on the desk,
why but we pretty much approve of your
comedy or do physicians be in the dust?
Why? That's great. That's great guys.
100% death squad approved
unanimously voted now
herpes so happy.
It's still,
it's a noise but we don't really mean
the connotation of those words to connect
it together. Like death squad.
It became something else.
And even though it has that name,
we don't think of any.
There's no death involved.
You know, there's no squad.
It's like a bunch of silly happy people,
you know,
but they're just ironically call
themselves desk with the Highland Kathy.
That really does it tomorrow,
Ladies and gentlemen will be our
300th mother fucking episode.
Yes,
you guys were to 99 and joining us
tomorrow will be none other than the Great
Joey Coco Diaz allegedly cock sucker.
He never know what Joey,
you never know what's going to happen.
It's part of the fun and it's,
it's also baby too. You never
know if he's night. Joey Diaz,
his wife is about to hatch.
I'm knew Joey d a female.
Joey Diaz,
who will no doubt be the
funniest girl in preschool.
It's going to come out of Joey.
I took her to babysit their kid tonight.
I'm cracking jokes right away.
It's going to be very interesting.
Joey will be with us Friday night at
the Wiltern honey, honey, Joey Diaz,
Doug's Stan hope and me. It's going
to be awesome. And, uh, listen,
I got all these emails from all these
different people saying they're coming
from all over the world. We appreciate
the fuck out of that. And we're,
we're very excited and I'm
so glad that we, we, we,
Doug and I talked about
doing this probably in 2003
when we first started doing
our shitty version of the man show and
we said we should have an end of the
world party and a, and we're doing
it Joe rogan.net, my comedy special.
It's already out.
It's supposed to.
I'm supposed to not talk
about it til tomorrow,
but a bunch of people have already saw
it on Twitter while this podcast was
going on and said they loved it. Which
uh, uh, I'm very happy here. I'm,
I'm really happy for it. I don't, I
would never put it out of its socket.
I worked really hard on,
this is like a good solid
year of preparation and uh,
and then it was a long time to set up
the infrastructure to sell this and to be
able to distribute it online. Uh, what
Louis Ck did is a real game changer.
It sort of changed the way a
lot of people, especially the,
certainly the way I think about it.
Um,
releasing things like this was never
even an option or consideration until we
started doing this podcast. So thank
you very much. We appreciate it.
The fuck out of you guys.
We were all in this together.
It's helping me as much as it's
helping you guys. I swear to God,
I'm gonna believe in God and I swear
to him, I swear I believe in Odin
and sent him praise. Praise
Odin. Ladies and gentlemen.
It's not that I don't believe in
God. Let me read it. Said I don't, I,
I don't believe in him and I don't
not believe in him. If he was there,
I wouldn't be shocked.
Life itself is fucking crazy as
an operating system could be.
God could be the,
the guy who programmed the simulation.
It can be some autistic kid in Seattle,
the fucking laptop. All right, you fucks.
Look, we loved that Shit Outta Ya. We're
sending out positive messages to you.
Take them in and do with them what
you will and we'll see you tomorrow.
[inaudible].